[Music]
[Music]
my
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey what's up
yeah we're sitting here discussing this
[ __ ]
that's what always happens with that
[ __ ] yeah aztec sundial going on like
out of [ __ ] the little shaft of light
that comes in
the one right if it hits like right
there that means like it's the end of
the world or we find the arc of the
covenant yeah that's right
looking for the city of tennis
that's right yeah and it's like it's
like a couple little circles this inch
in diameter one above the other it's the
places where the little joints and the
damn
blinds are tied yeah because i have one
of the blinds in that window is like
broken like half of it's broken off it
was like that when we got here but the
shaft of light has already passed to the
place where the lens on the camera yeah
it's usually at this time of year
i've noticed uh it's somewhere between
like 4 30 and 4 45 you get like this
this shaft of light that comes in like
whites out the screen for like
white shafts
[Laughter]
speaking of white shad
she's getting white shafts tila's not
gonna make it tonight she's got a date
on [ __ ] only fans
she's streaming some kind of live ir act
or something i don't know what it is oh
my goodness yeah her and her hubby armor
look at you megan speaking of urban
legends
yeah i know a lot of tina's fans are on
there
flirting with [ __ ] tila in the
comments section so based on her little
[ __ ] icon that goes many girls
[ __ ] good looking man girls ah that
says man [ __ ] t was probably a dude
[Laughter]
never seen never seen any kind of social
media other than the little [ __ ]
little see i've always kind of dude you
know i've always kind of wanted to be
curious i'm always well i'm not i'm not
curious enough to actually do it now i'm
not curious enough to actually do it but
i'm always kind of interested to you
know make another account
like as
a guy and see like how it's different
yeah and i kind of you should make a you
should make an account like a hot woman
and put that and see and see the
[ __ ] that you get like on a daily
basis well set up a facebook set up all
kind of i guarantee you that like within
a day or two you will get so much like
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm a predator
i know i'm just saying out of my mind
i'm just saying
it would be interesting for you to see
though like all of the [ __ ] that you
had dj maniac following me he's [ __ ]
sending me [ __ ] super chats and [ __ ]
i feel like some fake chick [ __ ]
sending them [ __ ] pictures and [ __ ]
then he's sending me [ __ ] video clips
been [ __ ]
doing [ __ ] epson [ __ ] and then i'll
build a whole [ __ ] portfolio of dirt
on him come back later hey man a dirt
portfolio yeah dirt portfolio send me 10
grand or i'm gonna post this up on your
facebook
that's not that dude's doing that that's
the birthday yeah i know
yeah that that actually did actually it
uh i was listening to one of those it
was mr nightmare or something like that
and he was doing like some reddit things
and one of the things was like the theme
for these stories was stalkers
and this guy and it's from they're
usually from no sleep or creepy pasta so
they're probably not real because that's
kind of the whole conceit of that is
that you're writing like fictional
stories that you're pretending are real
some of them might be real i don't know
yeah but
this person got that they got like
somebody had they had all their personal
info like they had their address they
had all their pictures they had all
their passwords and everything like that
and then they tried to like blackmail
the person and
most of the time i think it's probably
better to just like ignore that kind of
[ __ ] because honestly you can post
whatever the [ __ ] you want about my i
have no shame so i don't really care
maniac just posted that joke's on you i
have no [ __ ] exactly that's how you got
to play it don't send anybody anything
that you don't [ __ ] care if the
public wants to see so your [ __ ] better
look good you said you better be putting
on a performance of the [ __ ] life and
if it doesn't look good then you have to
not care about it yeah yeah that [ __ ]
better look good as [ __ ]
because that's the whole thing that's
not blackmail that's promotion yeah and
they start showing the whole reason that
that works is because people there's
things that people don't want
other people to see yeah and it's just
like i honestly can't think of a single
thing that i've ever done
on camera
that i would care if anybody put it
someplace i think we have some material
there we have to put the yoyo we do but
it's like
we do but i wouldn't really care that
much if it's like yeah it'd be
embarrassing it was basically you
attacking me in that manner it was yeah
well i mean it would it would be
embarrassing but i wouldn't be i'd be
like i'm just putting up with it i was
just putting up with it for sure i just
had to brace myself
yeah push it harder jennifer
oh my
god that was a long time ago though now
yeah that was a while back better now
than i did then though
yeah i think i do yeah
but you know it's like i said that and
that's what i was thinking of it's like
yeah we've got some stuff like that but
it's like i wouldn't really care i mean
i don't want it to get out but if it did
i wouldn't be that bothered about it no
it's like it's not it's it
it it isn't that's what i mean it's not
really they have to be re-edited and
make sure the [ __ ] everything was
[ __ ] cleaned up in terms of [ __ ]
lighting and effects and [ __ ] [ __ ]
make it look more promotional because
that was just spur of the moment [ __ ]
yeah we just heard it we just made it
for fun
[ __ ] get out in the [ __ ] of you
well yeah and you know it but it's like
maniac said if you don't care then it's
not dirt right then there's nothing they
can do to you and if the shit's high
quality it's not [ __ ] leverage at all
it's just promotional and to be fair uh
big money i mean the internet there's so
much porn and so much content on the
internet that probably no one would even
notice
it's a drop in the ocean yeah seriously
that's kind of so that's how i think
about them like even if it did get out
the chances of somebody i know seeing
that are like probably like next to
nothing and even if they did i wouldn't
really give a crap we know people that
[ __ ] have tried to do it for a living
and no one noticed they couldn't make it
that's what i'm saying it's just that
because there's so much of it out there
and we're talking about people that look
good yeah you know but see there's a lot
of people that look good yeah and
there's a lot of people doing it yeah no
it was kind of like nobody even noticed
that's kind of like well that's kind of
the flip side because remember we're
always kind of talking about how awesome
it is now like how uh the internet has
sort of like democratized a lot of
things but
the bad side the flip side of that is
now there's so much content out there
that to get noticed
is really difficult and really we're now
on the [ __ ] 1987 level of [ __ ]
running man
where you can't trust any imagery they
have [ __ ] deep fake technology they
say that is it's to the point now where
a lot of it's indistinguishable
they can do the voice well yeah i mean
there's like out of the running man and
there's kind of a whole subculture of
you know celebrity porn where people are
pasting like celebrity faces on actual
porn and animate it really you can turn
it into a mask where a person can say
something and the face moves just like
the person who's [ __ ] looking like
it's just like like a phone app
yeah but they say that it's it's getting
to the point where it's
indistinguishable right and they're
going to use that as a down political
weapon
but the thing about it political well
check this out
they're saying well it's going to be
dangerous because you won't be able to
believe the news [ __ ] the news most
people already don't believe that that's
what i'm saying it's like i think that
that horse has already left that
yeah um i think everybody pretty much
knows they know that that takes i mean
since photoshop has been around uh you
know you can't really trust photographs
somebody that [ __ ] hot at photoshop can
like make pretty much anything
uh and now that we have that with videos
so i think like the the current
generation of people that have grown up
with all that technology they will fall
for it they're already just kind of like
yeah facebook you'll see you'll see an
image of some candidate running for
office doing some outrageous [ __ ] or
saying some outrageous [ __ ] and [ __ ]
he'll say i didn't say that that's a
deep fake
and what they'll do is is everyone will
deep fake everyone so the only way to
combat that is not to come out and go i
didn't say that you say i didn't say
that but you also make another deep fake
of your opponent doing something similar
to that doing something worse or worse
[Laughter]
everyone running for office from every
political group will all of them have 30
or 40 [ __ ] scandalous [ __ ] videos
all about them all deep fakes so and no
one will pay attention
pay attention that's the public will be
like oh you can't trust any imagery
[ __ ] people believe what they want to
believe there's no centralized
information which is actually good
because it disempowers [ __ ] bad
organizations
politicians are bad all right they just
are
uh [ __ ] uh
people that run corporations are bad uh
you're just not gonna believe what you
see
which that's not a big deal
the society will swallow that i mean
it's been going on it's going on forever
it's called journalism it's just that
you know the technology to do it is much
better right you can just now make an
image
images back you know even back in the
[ __ ] 70s and 80s they were doing that
[ __ ] on [ __ ] weekly world news but
they didn't have photoshop so it was
kind of crude so you could tell that it
was fake there was stuff going on in the
90s
where cia wanted to do deep fakes deep
fake video of saddam hussein having sex
with an underage boy
to try to pull the rug out from
underneath them they never did it
evidently they didn't have the
technology or they figured it wouldn't i
kind of feel like it would be easier in
that regard just to get lookalikes yeah
i mean that would be much easier than
trying to like technologically like [ __ ]
with but um deep faking lying doing
false flags
been going on since
since before we were born
everybody does it
i remember when i [ __ ] joined the
army to go to the first gulf war
they deep faked us
they had some [ __ ] girl from from
kuwait come up and say that the iraqi
soldiers were throwing all the babies
out of the incubators on the floors and
killed them all totally fabricated so
that never happened
we were also deep faking [ __ ] skutt
attacks that never happened with the
help of cnn
so just because
other nations are deep faking and doing
false flags and [ __ ] don't for one
second think that we don't do it we do
it been doing it forever
it's just part of the game
if you want to wage war on somebody you
have to make an excuse to get the pub
you have to make an excuse
you need the public on your side so you
got to come up with a story to enrage
everybody here's how [ __ ] hardcore it
was
before actual fighting was starting
traditionally an army would send a
smaller group of itself into enemy
territory the excuse was it's a probe
but the full intent was to have that
small group wiped out
so it would enrage your army so the
morale would go up so they'd fight
harder
in the coming days of the opening
assault
it's just an old trick
been going on since like the 1500s
nothing to do
yeah that's why i don't get and yeah
inordinately worried about it because
i'm like yeah what else is new nope
they've been doing that forever it's
just the technology what's best about it
is the technology
the internet has brought people's
awareness
to these games you know i mean we now
know
and we can all talk about it now before
the internet we couldn't talk about it
you could it was a one-way communication
through the television set no comment
section
you know
people who you know couldn't talk to
each other about it you couldn't educate
one another about it the old systems are
falling apart
and that's a good thing
that's a good thing what will come is
freedom
freedom from them
your dependency from them
so
and they
that's kind of the [ __ ] uh an
offshoot of uh
urban legends
they can be manufactured
and they are kind of and but the urban
legend is actually kind of manufactured
out of the more ass
it's the bottom up
generally they're pretty organic because
some people have tried uh some
folklorists and stuff like that have
actually tried to start an urban legend
uh it doesn't work out as well
um as you might think i kind of feel
like urban legends generally proliferate
better when they
come about organically you know what i'm
saying let me go back and because i'm
trying to like answer some uh comments
and stuff camp guy says i can't think of
an urban legend except for the old hook
arm pulled off by the car yeah the hook
for a hand dude which is probably like
the first urban legend that i heard as a
kid
but actually that's good that you can't
think of that many because
i just went through and i told tom i was
like don't be alarmed because i know
like he looks at the length of my notes
and he's just like oh my god we're gonna
be here for eight hours
but i was like well we don't have to
necessarily discuss all of these these
are just ones that
i liked that i thought were creepy um
and i wanted a good mix of kind of like
classic ones and also kind of like maybe
lesser known or more regional ones and
just ones that i thought were creepy and
like i said i have a couple books down
here that i can refer to
and
but it's good that that's the only one
that you know because there's like a lot
of other classic ones that maybe you
haven't heard i mean i kind of feel like
everybody yeah everybody knows the hook
hand story like i said probably the
first urban legend i heard as a kid but
i kind of feel like there's other ones
that are really well known like
vanishing hitchhiker probably is you
know the other most common one i kind of
feel like but
i mean there's a lot of ones that i feel
like and maybe i don't know maybe like
you don't know
maybe you hear a story you don't like
realize it's an urban engine i don't
know
but i i find urban legends really
fascinating because
i love the way
that a lot of them are you know really
old or taken from old stories but you
know that are kind of like perpetually
being updated with new details
as
people like as society's anxieties
shift
and
they're then they're retold as true
stories i mean pretty much the
definition of an urban legend is
something that's probably not true it
might have like stemmed from a true
event sometimes it does but by the time
that it gets to a point where it's
proliferated where everybody has heard
it it's usually gathered a lot more
details it didn't have anything to do
with the original thing uh and it's
usually almost always
told as a true story but and it's almost
always told as a true story that
happened to
quote unquote a friend of a friend like
somebody oh like my mom knows this woman
at her hairdresser's whose boyfriend
said that blah blah blah so and then
people keep repeating it like it's a
true story but
after it goes through that many
iterations it's just interesting how
they kind of like pop up and they they
have like half-lives too because
sometimes a story will just pop out and
then it'll be everywhere suddenly and
everybody's telling it like it's a true
story so they almost kind of like go in
sort of trends which i think is
interesting
uh so
dj maniac recommended archive 81 series
on netflix i think you're the second
person to recommend that to us so we
will eventually get around to watching
it
um camp guy says i whoops oh i'm trying
to read and it like kind of flipped to
flip to something else i usually don't
believe in witches and devil worshipers
but i saw a serial killer expert that
says he expects individual dungeons in a
lot of neighborhoods i don't know though
because
back it runs back in the 80s when the at
the height of the satanic panic
they were able to find the odd cop or
quote unquote expert that was apparently
really convinced that satanic cults were
operating in all these cities and stuff
yeah and i'm just kind of like i'm less
inclined to believe like one dude
than
statistics yeah on youtube you will find
if you search for it
um there's at least one of them on there
a vhs tape
made for law enforcement to instruct law
enforcement about satanic yeah we talked
about it on our stage [ __ ] is [ __ ]
berserk it's bizarre and what the deal
what was with that
is he had a guy who um
tr was making a living as a um
an occult
how would you how would you describe him
an occult
expert yeah like an occult expert which
you can pretty much proclaim yourself at
to be honest and he was trying to sell
occult trade the training of the occult
to the law enforcement right so he's
just trying to make a buck sure training
pack and there were a lot of police
departments probably in those days in
the bible belt which that's what we're
in but the bible belt is not what it was
in the 80s those people are mostly dead
now
um
you'd had
local police departments let this guy
come in
sell those tapes show them and do like
little training seminars with the police
and filled and if you watch these videos
he's he was filling their heads full of
[ __ ] garbage yeah now whether it
whether the police believed it or not
i don't think they did because i don't
think they did because uh the claims in
the video were pretty uh flimsy
how to investigate a [ __ ]
scene a crime scene that had occult
[ __ ]
overtones to it i mean it was pretty
[ __ ] flimsy but when you see that
you'll see what the the satanic panic
was like
different it was a different time and it
definitely influenced by gerardo rivera
and [ __ ]
voy povich and [ __ ] all the sally
jesse raphael daytime talk show i mean
the whole satanic panic was just one big
series of interconnected urban legends
as far as i'm concerned and like i said
just because when i say something as an
urban legend that doesn't mean
that there might not necessarily have
been like the odd case here and there
sometimes there are and well like some
of the k some of the urban legends we'll
talk about did actually have a real case
behind them although sometimes you know
details changed late as it got retold
but most of them
are
made up out of whole cloth or are
variations on older stories or more kind
of like classic mythology type stories
like i said that reflect whatever the
anxieties are of that particular age
so for whatever reason i kind of feel
like the satanic panic and we talked
about this on our we did two satanic
panic shows actually
um i kind of feel like the sort of
counterculture movement of the late 60s
where a lot of people were
you know abandoning traditional religion
and looking for a little more like new
age kind of stuff that got people
anxious about what they might be up to
particularly like when you had real bad
[ __ ] like charles manson and all that
stuff yeah and so that kind of kicked
off
you know starting in the early 70s
all these kind of you know there's
movies and urban legends and stuff like
that the exorcist and all that kind of
stuff about
satanic cults operating
under the veneer of normalcy yeah
and a lot of that came this it was a
different world that was a time the 60s
was a time for cults you had scientology
you had a bunch of these all kinds of
these little bitty cults especially out
in california they sold real well
most of them were not
dangerous well and that's why people
don't care about them because you only
worry about getting laid yeah
and making money which you know some of
them like uh children of god that was
peta [ __ ] they were they were real
[ __ ] up
um but then you had some people jump
into it who tried to make money and
monetize it and get famous
like anton levate
anton levay
would have been kind of like a cross
between an early goth at a carny
he was kind of he was a little bit of
both in an entertainer
and he straight up
codified you know leviathan
religious satanism which is really more
based upon like friedrich nietzsche type
stuff and iron rand almost like a
self-help type [ __ ] thing
but it had a kind of a gothic [ __ ]
visual to it which
back in the 60s and the 70s could really
kind of enrapture
normies very exotic yeah very exciting
uh there wasn't much to it by today's
standards nowadays that wouldn't be
noticed it would just be kind of like
laughed off because it was larping
yeah people know what larping is now and
you guys satanist today that larp and do
all kinds of [ __ ] pranks like okay
you make that statue then we're gonna
make our statue to bathroom it i [ __ ]
find that [ __ ] hilarious because
i mean they're
ironically they're they're out there
doing the lord's work
because they're pointing out hypocrisy
is what they're doing that's kind of
their whole mission statement nowadays
which i'm i'm all for that the problem
is is that
if you want to say that the united
states is a religious country
then by the constitution you have to say
it's all religions
if it's all religions then it's also
satanism yep so and that's what they're
pointing to
now
there's a lot of writings you know some
say well you need kind of like a godly
type people that could uphold the uh the
ideas of a [ __ ] democratic republic
those are all decent arguments
but they were said but the people that
argued that back in the 1700s during the
during the enlightenment period those
are good guys
um
they were arguing from a viewpoint that
christianity had a monopoly on
good morals which that's not true
actually
many different kinds of people can have
good morals
what are morals if you ask me morals are
cultural values
that survive contact with reality and
allow people to prosper
and allow them to protect themselves and
allow them to flourish anything that
does not do that is not a good moral
just that's just my my opinion if it
works against you it isn't good if it
helps you it's good
it's just that simple
uh so there are certain things in
christianity that are not good
but what's funny is that these christian
groups don't promote those particular
values those have kind of fallen into
the
into disuse because christianity is many
things when you actually go to the
scripture and for every one thing it
says it says exactly the opposite
somewhere else yeah like
here's an example
in certain places it will say
you know uh
in the pauline epistles it'll it'll ask
you know
it'll say [ __ ] like
of um
some the question we asked should we
eat
meat that has been sacrificed to pagan
idols they're talking about rome they
would sacrifice meat to idols and then
after the sacrifice would happen they'd
eat that idol
or they'd eat that meat if you're a
christian guest in a roman home
should you be able is it a sin to eat
that meat it was sacrificed to
the idol of another god
the bible's answer would be say oh well
of course you can eat it if you long as
you know that that is a pagan idol and
that it doesn't exist it's polite to go
ahead and eat that because that is not a
real god but then later it says but if
god finds out you eat that he will
[ __ ] kill you
so it says two different things in two
different places always pretty much
they say there's no contradictions in it
no there are a lot of contradictions uh
yeah
have they actually read that
they're not
so a lot of the things that are not
popular anymore are not used
in christianity but what's left is kind
of like
public or christianity or
um
cultural christianity you know because
it says a lot of things it says be good
to your children but then it says kill
your children if they disobey god at the
same time
in different places
maybe too it doesn't mean to an extent
they're like well that is being good to
your children because you're like taking
them out because
each one of those books were standalone
books written by different authors
they're compiled together over hundreds
and hundreds over hundreds of years
compiled together in a
cultural archive they're they've been
edited to slightly harmonize but there
are little details that were never
harmonized
yeah so
the stuff that you're not using is that
christianity
yeah it is it's just that you're not
using that
the same kind of thing happens in
cultural islam
big difference between cultural islamic
people and say isis
all right we have islamic uh subscribers
that i talk to assad is one of them he
lives in saudi arabia he will tell you
that [ __ ] guys that are really
hardcore and fundamentalist
they take that [ __ ] very seriously go
through the hadith and everything
they'll [ __ ] kill you all right
well we have some christians like that
here too like really hardcore like
fundamentalist ones yeah that'll like
shoot abortion doctors and [ __ ] yeah
yeah same thing right but that doesn't
mean it isn't christianity and that
doesn't mean that it isn't oh yeah i
never said it wasn't yeah it is
christian i'm just saying is islam it's
all on a spectrum it's just like just
like everything else and it's opinion
holy scripture can always be opinionized
well i kind of feel like the thing with
religion is that
and and one thing i've always said is
that you don't actually need religion to
be moral because
moral people will be moral no matter
what religion they are
uh immoral people will use religion to
justify their shittiness
you know what i mean
it's a it's not a greatest evil is to
lied and to twist and to harm other
people so you can get ahead of them yeah
especially if you're lying twisting and
trying to get ahead of people who you're
friends with
i've just boiled it down to
protect people who are your friends and
family okay that's the [ __ ] the main
thing
if they're your friends and family
you [ __ ] protect them
if someone is your enemy you go after
that person if they are actively trying
to get you yeah i mean they have to if
they're not then just like it's just
normal
obviously that's the universal law of
[ __ ] nature
the romans were real good at that the
romans were the [ __ ] masters of
creation and destruction the their
version of virtue was to be good to your
friends and your families and your
supporters that you're with them your
enemies you ruthlessly prosecute or
persecute them you kill them
if they're your enemies
because enemies are always trying to
kill you and the people that you're
that you're that that you're protecting
if they're not doing that they're not an
enemy
an enemy is an enemy
and uh that's that's the truth that's
what that's what it's really about
and what you're talking about is the
but let's analyze that what is that
that's the ideology of a mafia
that's what it is a mafia
but
that's what that's life
nation states are doing that
okay that's the way it actually is
may not may not like it but that's true
that's what truth is
we live in a ruthless world
granthar's hammer says which urban
legend is real richard gere and the
rectum stuffed gerbil not true or yeah
also not true not true uh rod stewart
drinking the bucket of smeg onstage not
true also not true not true also not
true yeah i remember those neither one
of those are true actually uh the whole
thing about ozzy osbourne biting the
head off the bat i think that's also not
true yeah not sure i think there might
have been something about a dove
i think it was it might have been a dove
not a bat
and but
he never admitted to that it actually
happened yeah
uh i think he might have stepped on a
dove by accident or something that was
thrown up on you gotta understand ozzie
will lie
to make his uh
his story sound more exciting
but uh from what i from what i remember
he's
from what he said during an interview
and this is more in the modern era
that wasn't a bat
somebody threw a dove on stage and he
says i didn't know it was real yeah it
got killed yeah i've heard that story
too right yeah so i don't know what
really happened nobody knows i wasn't
there
uh safe insane says cropsy actually that
is a very uh well-known urban legend
particularly in upstate new york but
we're not gonna talk about that one
because we talked about that one back on
the whole show on that we i don't think
we did a whole show about it but we did
a show
on
urban legends based or movies based on
urban legends or something like that and
uh it was one of like four topics that
we talked about so yeah we did talk
about the cropsy thing on another show i
have to look up i can't remember
good questions book about rural legends
and [ __ ] urban legends yeah good idea
yeah i mean the thing about it so when
you say urban legends it kind of implies
that they're just like city based but
honestly urban legends has
it's in a much more broader general
sense it means pretty much anything
that's like modern folklore so a lot of
them are set in like rural area areas
yeah you know what i mean actually a lot
of them are did you read the uh super
chat
no because i was that far back well yeah
i was trying there was like comments
back there that i wanted to read and i
didn't want to lose it and then you know
i'm too tall i'm talking and then you
were talking talking you were talking to
them
so thank you no need for me too posted
pics of the white paint job on the
patreon community page for myself yeah
you were talking about the mustang how
are you doing yeah three two now hold on
68 fastback is that what you said 69 69.
not saying fastback 3 or 2v8 that wasn't
the mach 3 i don't think that or
68 was that the one
i always liked the fastback bodies in
every model that came out i thought they
looked really good the notch back of the
[ __ ] fox body looked good
but the the fastback tended to be the
good look but i don't remember what 68
looked like
was was that called was that the mach 1
or was it the mach 3
that wasn't the bullet mustang was it
i'm trying to remember which one the 68
was
yeah let's see
straw dog 78 says jim morrison never
pulled his thing out on stage yeah
that's true he did get arrested for uh
exposure but i don't think he actually
did anything murder murder hornet's nest
said tom i got my test level it was
1117. that shit's highest but yeah
that's good 1100 1100 is good but it's
not as high as you you know it's not all
that 1400 1600 they got dudes like that
out there too
can you live like that i'm not sure but
when i i came off of everything i came
off of hrt
um i was like 9.50
yeah at 52 that was good
yeah dj maniac's time we were talking
about the rod stewart thing about uh you
know drinking the bucket of smeg um
yeah he points out uh the pumped stomach
has been applied to every pop star from
the 70s to modern day including marilyn
manson elton john eminem any any pop tv
you can think of that's what classifies
it as a as an urban legend because as
time goes on and different you know rock
stars get famous like
whoever is the most
perceived to be the most debauched or
whatever
that same
uh legend is spread about them because
honestly
the richard gere like gerbil up the butt
thing
i've heard that about other celebrities
as well
which like i said so obviously that's
not true i don't even like why would you
even think to do that who even thought
of that legend see this is kind of what
fascinates me about urban legends is
that they almost kind of like seem to
sometimes like come from nowhere
and it's kind of like it's
specifically like
a gerbil up someone's butt
where did that story come from i don't
think it happened anywhere i mean i'm
not saying it didn't happen somewhere it
might have there's some freaky ass
people out there but
why did it get specifically attributed
to richard gere i mean i've heard it
like i said i've heard it attributed to
other celebrities as well but richard
gere is usually the guy that gets
saddled with that
um so i wonder
where i'm not saying that i think it's
true i just wonder why that legend
and him specifically you know what i'm
saying why a gerbil
like they were jealous of him during
that time i think it's always some dude
that's real popular with women
and they come at him with some kind of a
something that's kind of like
like more even more uh controversial
than gay
he put a gerbil up his butt or he did
that or he drank a whole bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] calm from the rest of
the band or you know they pumped his
stomach and it was filled with a cow to
come yeah this is this is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's it's that did that to rod stewart i
remember because i was a little kid when
i when i heard that
and uh during that era rod stewart was i
had like number one hits he was [ __ ]
super popular
and [ __ ] women were buying his
records and they loved that dude
rod stewart was was a good looking dude
he could sing when he was young you know
the [ __ ] women liked him back in the
70s i remember
he was a sex symbol
it was the same thing with richard gere
richard gibb was a sex symbol at that
time pretty woman and everything
remember the movie pretty woman yeah
that's about when i heard the [ __ ]
gerbil story
when did that come out 1990
80s
i thought pretty woman was late 80s i
think it was 89 or 90. yeah i think it
was 1990 but i can't actually remember
i don't remember the first time i heard
the richard gear up that it just seems
uh again
and that's a ridiculous thing to begin
with that's what i made of this come on
like i said i'm not saying that someone
somewhere on earth hasn't done that at
some point because
people come up with some weird-ass [ __ ]
but you know if
just any brief perusal of like weird
fetish porn we'll show you that but
i don't know why that particular thing
why a gerbil why you know what i mean
they light it up i know but it's like it
just seems like so terrible because it
could fit it's so weirdly
they were common in people's houses as
little pets okay so they made that [ __ ]
and he's like oh my daughter had one say
hey i got an idea
[Laughter]
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] i just i kind
of feel like did we talk about the
richard gere and gerbil up the butt
before because i kind of feel like
remember we did the show about
rock and roll legends right like we
talked about uh robert johnson like
selling his soul to the devil and some
other stuff like that but
um we need to do another one of those
because that was like a fun show that
was a long time ago we did that but i
kind of feel like we mentioned that i
don't really remember pretty woman was
1990. see i got it okay
see i heard it around that time that's
why i heard it
i heard the richard gere thing
might have been before that jason willie
says apparently michael jackson slept in
an oxygen chamber and owned the elephant
man remains oh yeah he did he did
actually own the elephant room and i
don't remember about the oxygen chamber
but he did actually buy the uh the
elephant man skeleton a couple days ago
i actually went and watched a michael
jackson video it was bad the bad video
yeah i remember that because i i
stumbled across remember weird al
yankovic's fat video yes i saw that
yes i went back watch the original ham
on whole wheat and
i remember
that what's funny is uh
let's watch if you watch the bad video
for you normies you probably wouldn't
notice it but
michael jackson is gothed out as [ __ ]
he's got [ __ ] goth motorcycle pixie
boots with the [ __ ] buckles going up
the sides
[ __ ] tight [ __ ] black pants with a
red stripe he's got the [ __ ] leather
jacket and all the [ __ ] buckles he's
gothed out in that that that that was
similar to what see like daniel ash was
wearing
yeah at that time
and uh you know
daniel ashton [ __ ] guys who's from
bauhaus and who else dressed like that
kind of a little bit like susie
yeah a little bit
but
it's kind of funny how he would
pick out little things how michael
jackson would pick out little things
from the underground that he liked to
he'd bring that mainstream and mix it
with [ __ ] pop music and dance and
[ __ ]
and uh people would think that he
invented that now he stole that
but
he was he could dance man he was
entertaining
i didn't like him at the time but
he could make a he well
but politics has a lot to do with it
record stations would get behind him the
record companies get behind him and
they'd pump up they [ __ ] they would
pump out his [ __ ] music and try to
make as much money off as they possibly
could
but he was uh i'm glad that i lived
during the time i at least got to see
him when he was alive when he was doing
his [ __ ] he looked all right during the
bad video boy he [ __ ] his face up
later
but he looked all right during that time
dude this dude was weird jason willie
said the bad music video was directed by
martin scorsese
i forgot about that yeah yeah and he's
just trying to it was he was the first
very
very popular lesbian
[ __ ] star michael jackson
i was watching that and i got that's
that yeah he's lesbian
uh okay yeah
whatever first very probably
[Laughter]
no leave me alone leave me alone
[Laughter]
he was funny man when you think about it
that if you ask me none of that [ __ ]
aged well
none of it aged well
but
i'm
glad that i saw that [ __ ] as it was
happening though
because i think
i'm glad to have the context if a young
person of today were to see that they
don't think they'd get the context of
the times
john gore says that thriller video
though that was awesome yeah that's
really that was good john landis
directed that yeah yeah
no he was
real high quality [ __ ] man i could was a
little kid like i said he got movie
directors to work on that [ __ ] like
a-list yeah i mean i was a little kid
when the [ __ ] uh uh billie jean video
came out
and that was like the first really well
done music video
and some of the music kind of holds up
yeah i still like it yeah it kind of
holds up i like that song um
now
about what happened to him and
everything do i do i believe the
um
the allegations
yeah
yeah
i think so
but i mean they seem a little too
widespread to just been made up well i
just look at the architecture of his
houses
and the decorations of his houses now do
i believe
that those parents
sent their kids there to that guy's
house in good faith
[ __ ] no no i think the parents knew
exactly
i would never send my my kid to some
dude's house he's got a [ __ ]
amusement park in his front yard yeah i
don't care how far hell no
no i don't care what his name is or how
much money he has i know exactly what
you do
yeah
are you crazy yes that's exactly
now here's the thing
there's a there's a channel on there uh
a channel on youtube
it's called razer fist and razor fist
does a lot of metal reviews and he's a
michael jackson fan
and he actually talks about that case
and he handles it very fairly i believe
he believes it was a setup he's not
saying that mj didn't
go that way
but
he says that the parents knew and were
sending their kids there for a payday
and he believes that the kids that he
didn't actually do anything to those
kids
that he didn't do anything
that he was into it
but he was
a hands-off type guy
but that
that it was a setup a way to make money
on him and that's the possibility could
be
no normal
look
no straight guy that age with that
amount of money would not have who is
unmarried
that a rock star he would have a palace
with a filled [ __ ] single women in it
parties every night that's not what the
house would look like
it just wouldn't look like that
okay
so i believe he was uh
into kids well i mean he was very
stunted yeah emotionally i think he was
mentally at that level right and uh
was he actually doing anything to them
razorfist says no
says that he wasn't that he was kind of
celibate
that's a possibility
possibility
yeah i mean it's hard to say like i said
it's
he's kind of like a special case i guess
because
i i kind of feel like he had a child
like mentality so maybe he didn't really
see anything wrong with it but the rest
of the world are just kind of like yeah
dude that's creepy yeah
i think there was attraction there
there's a chance that he there's a
chance i say a 50 50 chance that he
didn't actually do anything
and i'm gonna give razorfish that yeah
there's a chance i don't know i'm
leaning toward he probably did but i
wasn't there so i don't know i mean it's
sketchy as [ __ ] it is sketchy razorfist
gives whatever razorfist gives a good
defense
it says that razorfist says yeah he was
into that but he probably wasn't doing
anything
we weren't there
john goris also says toby hooper did
billy idols dancing with myself that's
right great video love that video yeah
toby hooper texas chainsaw massacre fame
life force fun house i'm also a big fan
of flesh for fantasy video that's a
[ __ ] great i can't remember who
directed that one actually so it's just
like funny how you had like all these
kind of big directors directing music
videos back in the day well i mean look
well and i mean look at the ones
particularly the ones by like [ __ ]
duran duran which were kind of like
[ __ ] travelogue and cost like
millions of dollars to make yeah there's
like let's go to antigua and make this
[ __ ]
well
they would write and direct those things
and make millions of dollars just off of
[ __ ] five minutes of material
yeah i think you know what i mean that's
that was where the money was
yeah i'm in the 80s you can make like
[ __ ] tons of money off those [ __ ]
videos you know so they were like a lot
of them were like mini movies
uh sheila ann says the heart sisters
slept with each other that was another
rumor yeah i had actually never heard
that one
i never heard that one uh
evidently the barbie twins did they kind
of i just saw something i think well
dan bell like had some [ __ ] with them
like because you know how he splices in
like weird [ __ ]
yeah from old talk shows and
infomercials and stuff and he had
something on there about the barbie
twins and uh i had forgotten all about
them yeah they were
yeah they were they were models
big implants little skinny butts 80s 80s
[ __ ] kind of the cocoa type bottles
they were real good looking
um hot everybody liked them during the
day evidently the [ __ ] rich guys were
running through them and [ __ ] you
know they got [ __ ] pissed off at
dudes and
they kind of said that they were having
a relationship with each other that
that's and i wonder if they just said
that to be scandalous like to get
attention maybe maybe i mean because
some people say no that they were in a
would that be incest you're related but
you're actually biologically the same
person
it's still interesting
because you're still i mean you're
you're different people even though i
mean
yeah you're technically a clone of that
person but there's still like enough
differences to to be a different person
so yeah that's totally still an incest
that's like really weird that's another
urban legend i've never
they kind of i had never heard that i
never heard the one about heart though
i've never heard that
but uh i mean i've heard most of the
most of the urban legends but i've never
heard that one but yeah the barbie twins
but they see they came out and said that
though which makes me think they were
just trying to get attention maybe which
worked
you know
maybe
there are some twins that have done
weird [ __ ] in porn
that's true
that's true they have to [ __ ] adhere
to certain rules at least in the in in
the west but
or it would be illegal but they come
close
yeah yeah what i don't even actually
know what the incest laws are now on the
books nowadays because it's not really
something that ever occurs to me or that
i think about
but it may not be really tightly
specified in law what incest is well see
that's what i'm saying i think we
discussed this on some other thing we
were talking about somebody that married
their cousin and i said you know
everybody thinks that's kind of weird
nowadays but i think in a lot of states
that is actually legal yeah that you can
marry at first go well you can for sure
marry a second cousin because at that
point you're not really that related
that's where a lot of this [ __ ] first
cousin some states you can i think in
florida you can but i'm not actually
sure most your southern states you can
marry um
i mean if you want to i don't know why
but nobody does
yeah i don't know anybody that
that's like some old like 1800s yeah
that's from that's from that's from over
100 years ago when everybody lived on
like little small communities and there
wasn't anybody around so everyone was
kind of related to you anyway so you
didn't have much choice people are long
gone
you know and i don't think they don't
think they really differentiated between
first cousin and second cousin it's just
kind of like they're all the same family
clan as long as it wasn't brother and
sister you
you were all right
but that led to a lot of problems but
eugenics took care of that you know what
i mean a lot of people don't realize
that eugenics was applied to get against
like a poor country people that [ __ ] was
going on
especially in appalachia
what a lot of inbreeding interestingly i
have a few urban legends relating to
quote unquote deformed country people
yeah melon heads
the gulch people yeah gulch people go
ahead some people apple farm people i've
heard all different kinds of weird
[ __ ]
the faceless people yeah
there's all kind of like what my
ex-girlfriend name was stephanie she was
from i met her in boston she was from
new hampshire and
she grew up with a tale i think they
were called the apple farm people
and it was an inbred
family
they were running an apple farm
and
it got roped off by the state and they
became kind of like wards of the state
they weren't really kind of allowed to
leave there
kind of like that that inbred family
that you'll see on youtube the damn
drooling and the buck teeth and [ __ ]
that just scared me man that was
appalachia
but uh
there was a lot of that but
a lot of they had to do there was no
interstate system there wasn't any
freeways so you'd have isolated pockets
of 300 people totally cut off from the
outside world living in a place for
generations that are that time is long
gone
interstate highways and freeways brought
all that to an end
people but there's a lot of urban
legends still uh linger from that era
because there's a lot of urban legends
and i don't know how true they are
about like weirdly deformed like pockets
of people like living back that
sometimes like eat people and [ __ ]
babies and whatnot in the 1800s as
states would start to expand and start
making roads they'd find areas that had
been secluded for a hundred years
with [ __ ] in in early 1900s hundreds
of years
and uh those people were basically
eradicated
when you think about it yeah they'd go
in there and they'd sterilize them all
gone eugenics eugenics programs the
early 1900s
yeah because i there i mean the laws
back then were just kind of like and i
think i remember and
man this is a long time ago that i read
about this but there was actually well
there used to be a law that if you were
uh mentally disabled yeah you they could
sterilize you in some states in some
states because they didn't want you to
reproduce they didn't want to like you
to carry on your defective genetics
that's because of what they were running
into they'd run in
roads would lead the constructions of
roads
would unlock places where they had been
genetically isolated for over 100 years
and there was nobody in that area that
wasn't related to each other and they
were all mentally defective there's
photographs of it
and they would go in there and go we
can't have this because no one no
outsider would breed with them so
there's no way to reverse it so they
just go in there and sterilize them
what do you do with them yeah because
they didn't want it to continue they
didn't want it to continue i mean
because the more they kept [ __ ] and
reproducing like yeah more they would
just continue you'd get like some hp
lovecraft [ __ ] happening and they were
so [ __ ] up looking that no no outsider
would want anything to do with them so
it would just
continue
so they'd go in there and sterilize them
now there are horror stories there were
people that shouldn't have been
sterilized that were like if you went to
jail they'd sterilize it for an early
release that kind of weird [ __ ]
yeah because they do well for a long
time they thought like uh criminality
was genetic which i guess to a small
degree it probably is it might be but i
kind of look really [ __ ] up you
probably people will reject you and
you'll fall into a life that's another
thing too like so
to that extent it might have a genetic
component because yeah if you look
really like ugly or you look like a
quote unquote criminal or what people
yeah people will perceive then people
will treat you that way accordingly
right which might make you resentful
which will make you act out so so it so
in a lot of ways and like i said this is
kind of when we talk about serial
killers it's kind of like a combination
of genetics and environment
and that's that's very animal behavior
same thing happens with big cats
if a big cat is born there's something
wrong with it it's rejected by the other
cats
and uh
cats are social like lions you know
they're social they like to be so they
start acting bad they'll [ __ ] try to
eat they they don't hunt well on their
own because it's hard to survive on your
own
in the cat world so they start doing
things like
attacking cubs
inside the damn lion pride because those
are easy meals the other lions kill them
that would be a criminal
yeah by human standards yeah and it's
because that lion was looked bad
it's that simple just that simple that
was a funny looking lion funny looking
line
bad jeans
yeah so yeah how you look can affect how
people treat you which affects
what you have to do to survive
sad
but true that's the world we live in we
live in the animal kingdom we don't live
in
[ __ ] fairyland
unfortunately but the thing about it
though is that humans at least have the
wherewithal to like understand that to
some degree
so some
you talking about over 100 iq yeah under
100 iq no
the dumber humans are the more
superficial they are
then the smarter they get the more
superficial they are because they
understand the effects of superficiality
um
midwifes tend to try to
kind of which is you know 120 to 140
they try to rationalize it and make it
sound a little bit better but they're
full of [ __ ]
it is what it is
is that you creaking yeah yeah okay life
sucks it's cruel then you die
that's the truth that's the spirit time
yeah
fight back you're gonna die anyway
that's the spirit
it's only a matter of time what is she
doing in there i don't know what she's
doing
i keep hearing like weird noises i think
pookie's in the bathroom like trying to
she's trying to get in the cabinet or
jumping up on the mirror or something
like that well since like i said i have
like this big huge list and i'm just
gonna like scroll through [ __ ] since we
were talking about
uh weird creepy deformed people living
in the woods i do actually have a few
urban legends like that okay so
maybe we'll get into that so and then we
can just i don't know we'll just like
hop around
um
so
melonheads
now this is a pretty common uh urban
legend in
michigan so i don't know if you've ever
heard this because i know you lived in
michigan for a while also in ohio
connecticut uh that region
now i had heard of this before and i
don't think
i was gonna do a show on it but like
just them specifically but i didn't know
if it was like substantive enough i
think i did it on one of my like old
shows where i did like those just those
little uh
kind of compilations of stuff
but what these are
melon heads
are supposedly these little
humanoids
i guess they're either kids or they're
stunted adults to some degree
and they have like big like bulbous
heads like they're hydrocephalic
that type of situation
now uh there's different versions of
this normally they live out in the woods
somewhere like i said in michigan or
ohio wherever there's different like
strains of this legend
but
and there's different stories about
their origins
but normally what they would do they
hide out there and then like if you go
out into their
territory then they might like pop out
and like bite you or eat you even
so uh so there's that so
the story that is proliferating around
michigan
so the melon heads
they are there's a place called felt
mansion and they're supposed to hang out
there
now
apparently
this strain of the legend says that they
were
originally um
hydrocephalic children
and they lived at this insane asylum
uh near the mansion
now
after like i guess at the asylum they
were abused
and so
i guess apparently like either the
insane asylum closed or they escaped
there's different versions of the story
and then they went feral
and then they started living just in the
woods around the asylum
now
i don't really know if this asylum that
is supposedly at the heart of this
legend ever existed or not i think there
was actually a prison or something like
that around that same area so maybe
that's what people are talking about
but
yeah so so these things supposedly live
in the woods um you know melon heads or
i've seen them called wobble heads as
well
um
some all some other versions of the
story say that the kids also like maybe
lived in the mansion rather than the
insane asylum but then when they escaped
from there because of abuse or whatever
they went and lived into
like went and lived in these caves that
are like around there
or in an abandoned zoo nearby
um
also some versions say that they killed
the doctor that was mistreating them
because in some versions the doctor
yeah the kids had were hydrocephalic but
the doctor for some reason wanted to
make them even more so so he would like
inject water into their heads
so well yeah it's an urban legend like i
said it didn't really happen
but um but yeah so that's another one so
so in a lot of the versions like the the
kids all like rose up and like killed
the doctor and then escaped out of the
woods and like lived in the caves or
whatever and have been living out there
feral ever since
um
you know they killed the doctor and cut
his body up and [ __ ] like that uh you
know and there's ghost stories
associated with the with the area that
came along later on i guess they made a
movie in 2011 that's called the melon
heads and that's about like the michigan
strain of the urban legend now there's
also another version of this urban
legend uh which is kind of more centered
around ohio
uh specifically cleveland area
now
in this version the melon heads were
these kids and they were orphans
and they were
again under the care of a doctor usually
called dr crow
but sometimes he's given different names
and he um was doing like weird [ __ ]
experiments on them and stuff
and
so
i guess the kids were normal to start
out with
and then he was doing experiments on
them that made their heads get really
big and bulbous and then their bodies
get all deformed
um so
sometimes the kids were normal sometimes
they are were already deformed and he
made them mortified
um yeah so
this version which is in ohio he killed
they killed the doctor they burned down
the orphanage where they lived and then
went into the surrounding forest and
live out there and they supposedly feed
on babies where they're getting these
babies i don't really know i don't know
like why anybody's like walking around
like [ __ ] woods in ohio like with
their babies or like leaving babies
anywhere for them but supposedly they
eat babies and some of them like eat
just like regular ass people that kind
of like walk around there
and there's another version from
connecticut now interestingly
everywhere that have pretty much
everywhere that has this melon head
legend
there where they live
uh you know whether it's the abandoned
building or caves or whatever
is usually said to be a street
called quote unquote dracula drive
okay and it's usually just like a road
yeah it's just usually like a road
through the woods like a single road
through the woods now a lot of different
towns
have
just these kind of like you know one or
two lane roads going through the woods
right i mean it's you know michigan ohio
connecticut so out in the woods and
so there's a bunch of different streets
in all of these different areas
that are
known by locals as dracula drive even
though none of them are actually called
that
but because this legend has kind of
spread over this whole region
for whatever reason
there's always one street in that area
that's called dracula drive and that's
where the melon heads live and you can't
go down there because if you go down
there the melon heads are all going to
jump out and like eat you
doesn't sound too creative to me it's
well no i'm just saying but it's real
it's related to what you were talking
about earlier about and well as i said
the the thing that's always interested
me about urban legends because i've been
into urban legends like forever like
look okay i even have this if you
anybody that knows anything about urban
legends probably the premier folklorist
in the us is uh john harold brunband
hopefully i'm pronouncing that right and
um he was i don't know if he still is
but he was a professor at the university
of
utah i think
he wrote a whole bunch of books about
urban legends this is i have this one
this you know this is the only one i own
but he's written a couple other ones one
was called the vanishing hitchhiker one
was called the choking doberman one was
called the mexican pet and he's uh
written us and i've read all of those
like over the years uh but i checked
them out of the library so this is
actually the only one i own
this came out in 1989 and it's actually
really really good so this had all the
urban legends that were popular in the
late 80s that he's talking about because
he wrote a column uh like a syndicated
column like in newspapers and people
would send him you know he was right
there next to like anne landers and all
that kind of [ __ ] and people would send
him like urban legends from different
parts of the country and he would like
track
where they came from is this like a
version of an older story that's you
know just been changed to suit the new
technology or whatever and he's trying
to figure out was this based on a real
you know thing that happened somewhere
you know and so he's like really into
that kind of stuff so i mean i started
reading that stuff when i was a teenager
and i got really really interested in it
because
i don't know this whole kind of thing
about
this modern folklore because i've said
before like you know even like ancient
mythology and stuff is really
fascinating to me because
often
uh a culture's mythology
whether it's quote unquote ancient
mythology or you know religion or
whatever or whether it's urban folklore
uh says a great deal about the culture
that maybe the culture isn't aware that
that they're saying in the in that
folklore you know what i'm saying some
of it's sold though we don't know what
it means
well yeah that well that's why i'm kind
of a lot more interested in like modern
folklore because you can really tell
like what anxieties are being
perpetrated and i kind of feel like a
lot of these
stories like the melon heads and stuff
like that
that's kind of like an a more urban
anxiety about
these sort of quote unquote backwards
country people that might be lurking
around back there same thing as like you
know movies that came out the 70s like
texas chainsaw massacre hills have eyes
stuff like that uh you know deliverance
where you know you're thinking like oh
you're this urban city people like the
city dweller and you're going to go
out into the woods like a vacation and
there's going to be like these weird
[ __ ] deformed
freakazoids out there that are going to
eat you
well some of these have like you know
grains of truth to them which is why
people uh you know continue to tell the
stories because they sound plausible
yeah
i mean when i'd go visit my dad
in mississippi in the 70s
it was like going back to the 1930s in
certain ways i mean they had modern
technology but the culture was kind of
unchanged
in certain areas
yeah i can
so you can imagine what it was like in
the 1930s
in areas like that some of us it was
like still from the 1800s yeah so you
never know what you'd run into
but see we're not talking about some
kind of like
urban metropolitan you know up area up
north or in europe
you're in a [ __ ] tribal area
basically it would be called if it was
in any other country they would call or
in on any other continent they would
call it a tribal area
because that's kind of what it was
i can remember but uh
no you could go out there and find some
[ __ ] dudes in a town where every one
of their relatives owns or is in charge
of every [ __ ]
node of power the cops
the [ __ ] courts
the [ __ ] bags
the [ __ ] and it's like its own little
cult
and you say or do the wrong thing in
that town [ __ ]
the [ __ ] find you guilty of a [ __ ]
crime and [ __ ] execute you
that's the way it was back in those days
early 1900s
so so yeah i can understand how
rumors like or stories like this would
start
well there's a grain of truth to it
that's the thing and the reason why
urban legends why they're so popular is
because they sound plausible yeah and as
i said some of them were actually based
on a real event yeah at some point in
the past yeah but you know because it
had been told and retold so many times
that people forget the details add
details and [ __ ] like that like a game
of telephone now it doesn't really
resemble the original story anymore but
you can still go back and find that
kernel yeah where it came from now the
deliverance thing that [ __ ] like that
did happen but it wasn't
it wasn't you i wouldn't characterize it
that way
because i kind of seen that kind of
situation
what would happen is like the
mississippi natives would [ __ ] see
somebody that was from another state and
they would be amazed they wouldn't be
trying to rape you or kill you or
anything just be amazed
oh hey did ask you a bunch of questions
trying to figure out what it was like
well i mean unless you got unlucky and
came across that one that wanted to read
that's what that story is about it would
be that unlucky [ __ ] yeah but then they
would [ __ ] um do things like uh
comment on how odd you were
compared you know what i mean
your ways were odd
you know
those city ways you know that kind of
[ __ ] you know
to
there's something to what they're saying
but
nah
well maybe it had been different for me
because my dad was southern he's from
mississippi so they were easier on me
maybe if i didn't have any [ __ ]
southern relatives
then maybe they would get hostile
because they did not really like
outsiders
i mean [ __ ] our grandparents hated
northern's northerners hated them and
our parents didn't like them that much
but the further you go back in
in the generations
no [ __ ] my gran my grandmother
[ __ ] and my evidently my grandfather
he died before i was born they hated
yankees anybody they were enemies
they meant it
yeah my grandfather more than my
grandmother my grandmother was just kind
of like yeah whatever yeah
but you know my grandfather was always
yanking this and yeah [ __ ]
yeah and they they had their own [ __ ]
reasons and
they'd [ __ ] go on and on about it you
know what i mean um
they could not stand [ __ ] anybody
because the south had been conquered
and for many generations they considered
themselves conquered by people
and uh if you were a hardcore yankee but
if you came down here in the 70s
yeah you if you by yourself you kind of
probably were taking especially if you
went to some of the rural areas you were
kind of [ __ ] risking some [ __ ]
somebody might hurt you
somebody said i used to live in the town
where melon had supposedly lived it was
a strip of woods near the local pool but
since then they started building houses
there yeah i kind of feel like this is a
pretty common legend grantha's hammer
says i live in michigan melonheads have
been outlawed since 1983 a special
police unit called blade runners yes
hunt them down and retire them if you
know what i mean
but yeah well like i said it's
interesting because
yes there are like there are not so much
anymore but there were like pockets of
rural people that were maybe inbred and
they were maybe funny looking
and
so
that kind of got blown up into
this whole
legend that spread and like all these
extraneous details were added later on
you know
now it's like all these kids with like
big bulbous heads that eat babies you
know obviously that's ridiculous
but
it might have some
kernel of truth to it but it's just been
exaggerated so much that it's like not
true anymore you know
um
yeah murder hornet returns brought up
cropsy again too i said we're not going
to talk about cropsy because we talked
about him on
another show that was well the weird
thing about cropsy was that that was an
urban legend
that actually
came true after the fact because a
serial killer almost kind of like took
advantage of that urban legend
to
do his serial killerness
and that might be the only time that
that's happened yeah
oh well no i'm not gonna say that
because i will say you know the whole uh
urban legend about uh razor blades and
halloween candy and [ __ ] like that which
again urban legend but
in the 70s one dude did take advantage
of that urban legend
and put poison in his kids pixie stix
yeah and saying that it came from like
someone else's house so he
used the urban legend of the quote
unquote halloween sadist which is what
john harold burn van calls it uh to kill
his own kid for the insurance money yeah
but that's the only like documented time
that that's happened and it was the dead
kid's own dad yeah
uh granters is in there for the for
anybody who's new to you new to the show
me and grandpa's went to high school
together he retired law enforcement i'm
[ __ ] medically retired military
anyway uh he's saying that looking we
don't really uh make we don't really
hate southerners we just kind of make
fun of them
that's kind of how
right now at the level our generation
and maybe like my dad's generation most
of them are at that level in the south
now where they don't really hate
northerners
per se
they just will make fun of them they'll
tease them um
now we're in florida and a lot of people
that are here right now don't come from
here
so a lot of that's kind of
uh
not really a factor but you go to
louisiana mississippi tennessee alabama
that's still kinda you gotta watch it
around there they'll make fun of you
they won't [ __ ] physically attack you
unless you do something wrong it is not
a legal based society i'm gonna jenny
didn't grow up and didn't really spend
any time in mississippi mississippi is
not a legal base to culture
especially in the interior part of it
it's an honor based culture like any
other
tribal type society all right
they'll take [ __ ] into their own hands
they don't care what the laws are so
you've got to be careful in those areas
and it's not just white people black
people you piss off black people in the
south they will take care of it
themselves they don't call the cops
you know but
that's just the way it is here it's been
this way for [ __ ] centuries it's a
tribal kind of society but it's still
western and it's
the morality is kind of basically
christian
which you're talking about chivalry
you insult somebody
and you don't want to do that especially
not out in the country area
uh you can kill somebody and bury them
and they would you'd never be found
you got to be careful around that [ __ ]
man it is not
civilization as you know it but other
than that southerners are friendly as
[ __ ]
real friendly you just have to
understand the culture
there's a cultural
just
think of us as like the samurai it's
like [ __ ] it was like a
a gregarian [ __ ] society kind of like
feudal japan it was like that
and in certain areas it still is
maria says florida the farther north you
drive the more southern it gets yes
that's a very common panhandle is the
same as mississippi and alabama what i
was going to say is central and south
florida are
kind of southern depending on where you
are
um the more rural areas are obviously
more southern yeah but uh the panhandle
is very very southern that's alabama
mississippi it's the same thing the same
people granthurst hammer said when i
lived in north carolina people would
tell me they hated northerners but that
i was okay yeah
that's that's that's also common
it's just like southern white dudes
that's that they have to say they don't
like black people they have to say that
certain generations they had to say that
to get approval from other white people
but they would say i don't like black
people but i like billy he's all right
they go finish fishing which is really
weird because well that's what i mean my
dad was like that too yeah yeah it's
like he was always kind of like i mean
my dad like he would talk like he was
really racist
and then but then his best friend was a
black dude yeah yeah who worked at kfc
right which is
so
they they generalize
but then it's like well you're an
exception europe
right but every black person they know
is an exception right and that's the way
it's like so stupid
it's so stupid well okay a black person
would understand this all right because
you know i came up around black people
work with them a lot of my my best
friends are [ __ ] black club owners
and [ __ ]
the like big tom all right have a
[ __ ] we didn't need to have big time
on a show or a [ __ ] um you know
[ __ ] will bring will on the show
[ __ ] we'll explain it too i hang out
with ex-military black dudes around in
this area because we got something in
common you know a lot of these white
dudes i don't have anything in common
with
ex-military gothic black dudes which is
that's that's
that's [ __ ] hard to find those
anyway um
oh [ __ ] i forgot i was getting that
oh
what were we talking about i'm [ __ ]
drunk now i don't remember i was like i
was just trying to get back to my yeah
okay go back up
i don't know what it was i remember what
it was there it was it was okay what it
is is is uh
in black culture it'd be like being real
yeah i mean
um in other words not being not being
not selling out to the man
well
southern whites had the same thing
being friends with black people might be
considered to be selling out to other
white people especially if like for my
my dad's generation not so much but
really my grandparents generation they
were really like that
to be friends with black people would be
selling out
but here's the deal so they were
constantly trying to reinforce that they
were white
all right
and that they were not selling out
but the black people that they knew were
good black people it was okay that's
okay to like them you see
so it was silly but it was social
pressure black black dudes do the same
thing yeah [ __ ] on a white man [ __ ] the
man isn't it now he's all right he you
know he's uh he's all right that's why
boy he's okay
the other one's no
it's the same dynamic exactly well like
i said it's it's a very human thing to
other people who aren't like you right
but then when you meet well it's just
kind of like the stereotypical
somebody that's really sheltered for
example that grew up you know again for
example in a fundamentalist household
and it's just like you know
whatever they hate gay people because
they don't know any but then when you
meet one she's like oh my god they're
just like a normal person or they hate
atheists until they meet one it's like
oh my god you're a regular person
so it's like then
you know it the fact that you have like
an individual it's like that you thought
was everything you hated but you met a
person like that that was just like you
and that kind of like expands your mind
a little bit modern terminology would be
uh virtue signaling white p southern
whites and blacks had the virtue signal
to their own kind that they were with
their own kind so therefore black people
or white people were not good except the
ones that you knew they were okay
and that that's kind of why
no matter what it happened in the big
picture usually when it comes between
individuals
that know each other in the south white
or black they got along like [ __ ] my
dad is now in an all-black town [ __ ]
heidelberg mississippi is now pretty
much all black he's the last white guy
he loves those [ __ ] people they watch
out for him
you know they called the ambulance when
he was having a heart attack
knows all his neighbors he's friends
with all his neighbors
and
well times have changed that's my that's
my dad's rationale with it you know what
i mean but black people just saved his
life he knows that
he knows that he loves them and [ __ ]
he's up in the hospital during when i
left the show to go for my dad's [ __ ]
heart bypass his neighbors who are black
people are there [ __ ] at the hospital
and mr ross gonna be all right
and it's it's because they're
southerners and their neighbors it's
just it's it's country it's just the way
it is yeah it's like a small town it's a
small town everybody looks out for each
other yeah they're all watching out for
each other you know [ __ ] calling
[ __ ] somebody hey do you know that
person somebody just went on your
property it's like that it doesn't the
color doesn't matter
the color was the the race thing was an
artificial thing laid over it by history
they didn't choose that it's just the
culture they grew up in
it takes generations for [ __ ] to kind of
work themselves out the country people
and city people are always going to be
different
and i i like the kind of
in between i like to live in the country
but i go into the city have fun
yeah uh i wouldn't want to live in a
city i've lived in boston lived in lived
in the biggest city in the world at the
time with sao paulo brazil you know
[ __ ]
there's limits to what you can do in an
urban environment it's just
it's restrictive
i like to shoot guns and ride
motorcycles and have fun and not have
people watching me all the time
although in a way i kind of like bigger
cities because they're more anonymous
uh well when you're having fun well when
you're partying that's what i mean well
you know can you would think that oh
everybody's like watch but they're not i
kind of felt like more i felt more
watched in smaller towns because
everybody kind of knows you or at least
knows somebody that knows you so
everybody's like all up in your [ __ ]
constantly
uh i would rather be in a big city where
no no [ __ ] knew me and you could just
like walk around and like nobody would
know who you are i guess this argument's
the difference like i said i like the
ana and anonymity of like here's that
too it's just like if i want to build a
motorcycle i want to build in my own
garage i don't want people to do it i
don't right see i don't really like care
about that so it's like that doesn't
really bother me reloading [ __ ]
pistol or rifle ammunition go shooting
guns you can't really do that in the
town there's a lot of [ __ ] that i like
to do you can't do it a city
yeah you have to be in the country to do
it
tammy says wasn't there a story about a
woman that hid in a man's closet and
lived like that for years she would come
out when he went to work i've seen
several like that i'm not sure how many
of them are fake because it does seem
like some of them were reported in like
newspapers and [ __ ] like that but a lot
of urban legends get reported in
newspapers too as true so i'm not
actually sure because you could actually
fake that
um but usually the story goes some guy
lives in an apartment by himself and
he's just like man my food keeps
disappearing and he can't figure out why
so he sets up
you know uh
a secret camera whatever
uh in his house and then you see like a
girl like climbing out of like the cabin
or the attic or whatever the whatever
the hell and she's been like living
there the whole time and like coming out
and like eating food while he's gone and
[ __ ] like that um the ones that i've
heard that i do think is true is you'll
hear ones where
somebody who's a homeless person living
in someone's addict that they can get
yeah i've heard of that which like
that's not crazy that's not that crazy
they hear noises upstairs every now and
then and they never could figure out
what it was uh something might be
missing every now and then and then they
find a place where somebody had made a
bed and had a radio with headphones and
they had [ __ ] you know batteries and
they were living up in somebody's attic
but that's normally in like a
in a cold colder
up north environment and that somebody
do it from and i believe that that there
is something to that that that happens
every night yeah like i said that to me
does not seem that far-fetched it's it's
more far-fetched the smaller the
apartment is that you're talking about
if you're talking about like kind of a
big rambling like old farmhouse with a
big attic and you never go up there
right yeah i can see that
um and they're coming in from the
outside and they're coming in from the
outside and you don't see yeah i could
see that that that could happen for a
while without you noticing um tiny
apartment
i don't know i kind of feel like you'd
maybe discover that
after after uh not too long
um you know but yeah the one i saw i saw
the one that you guys were talking about
i think it happened in japan
and
that one i'm not sure i buy it because
it's just i mean that was a pretty small
apartment and she lived in like a
cabinet or something and i find it very
hard to believe that she had been doing
that for a really long time without the
dude
hearing anything you know what i mean
yeah
i don't know it's it's not impossible
but
it seems unlikely tammy says she's
living in uh virginia and people are
giving her crap being a yankee from
pennsylvania it's just gonna happen
it's just gonna happen
you gotta [ __ ] show solidarity
with them somehow depending on who they
are
which you gotta make friends with people
that's the only way
and
you know politics are gonna the main
thing is politics you have to understand
that the south
traditionally sees itself as a conquered
area
of exploited people all right and that
um
they're used up as soldiers for the
empire and that they're kept
artificially poor
by bankers from the north and
now that's changing because
most of your big industries are moving
into the southern states now
because business environments a lot
better here
uh the living you can live for a lot
less and get a lot more so it is kind of
changing and in a way you know what i
mean they're making fun of me [ __ ]
grandpa's making fun in a way the south
has risen again
uh south has good traditional values but
it's tolerant enough to where you can
have [ __ ] fetish clubs here
okay depending on where you don't know
where you are
all right you couldn't open one here
where we live right now no but there's
downtown yeah but downtown yeah
yeah but that's that's part of the game
it's just a game
yeah
um
but you know being born in california
and living in california as a kid up
until [ __ ] 83.
isn't a big difference between where i'm
at right now in florida and say certain
parts of like um northern california or
old southern california from the 70s
like san diego this is to me
florida of today feels a lot like san
diego of the 70s
which was open-minded had a lot of fun
semi-hick
but
you could you had enough freedom to kind
of do what you want the [ __ ] things
were kind of affordably priced and um
you had a lot of cool people moving into
the area it's like that
you know places [ __ ] waxing wayne
with popularity your place will get used
up and then people will move to the
other ones and
it reminds me a lot of early california
which that's great you know i like that
camp guy said there was a rich lady back
in the 1920s who had her boyfriend slash
lover live in her attic for like 15 to
20 years and her husband was an
alcoholic businessman and he never knew
i don't think that's impossible i could
see that i could see that i mean
depending on the businessman how
clueless was the dude i've met some
clueless dudes in my time timing it
would have a lot to do with it
guy up there when he's coming and going
and what's he doing is he sleeping there
mostly yeah i mean yeah you could do it
i could totally see that yeah like i
said if it was a big house
if the husband wasn't all that attentive
or observant um you know if he was at
work all the time yeah or whatever yeah
you could totally get away with that it
would be difficult
uh you know it seems like too much
trouble but you know you do you lady
seriously
you want to keep somebody upstairs so uh
since we were talking about
kind of deform people and since you
lived in louisiana yeah have you ever
heard this it's not louisiana it's
louisiana yes whatever okay so have you
heard the
uh the legend of the grunch people no
never heard of you you have not heard of
the ground watch people never grunt
people it must be something out in a
bite this is east new orleans east new
orleans
and it's kind of a similar thing uh so
story goes like i said it's an urban
legend
story goes that back in the old days in
the 1800s
uh there were these people that were
supposedly it was a whole bunch of
different whole like community people
and they were like combo
out they were like albino dwarves
pretty much like a whole bunch of albino
dwarves okay here it comes um so people
back into the understanding now grunts
people crush people yeah i have i'm
already envisioning it i'm already
envisioning it yeah okay story goes that
myself in [ __ ] ass mode the
the community because back in the 1800s
everybody thought like if you had if you
were kind of [ __ ] up look and
everybody thought oh the devil did it
you know what i mean so they the albino
dwarves kind of got like run out of town
and like out into the sticks right
because you know they were supposed to
be in league with the devil because they
looked [ __ ] up yeah yeah
they'd be poor stars well yeah yeah
you'd have your own make all kindly fans
sure yeah you know there's a niche for
everything i'm just saying
um
so apparently this isolated community
the grunge people started like
interbreeding obviously because no one
else would breed with them and so
their offspring like got more and more
like monstrous looking
so they live out in the woods
in east new orleans um but of course
you know as is the way with most of
these urban legends but like you know
teenagers hear the story and they're
like oh we gotta go check that [ __ ] out
so they kind of go out there and like
see where that is so the road where they
supposedly lived was called the grunch
road which is why they're called the
grunge people and it's supposed to be
this road where you know teenagers would
go like i said they go make out or smoke
or drink or whatever the hell uh and
then story goes uh that teenagers would
do that like on a dare but then after a
while like some of the teenagers started
like disappearing
and uh some of the ones that didn't
disappear would come back and say yeah
we saw these things that look kind of
like alpine dwarves like out in the
woods
um so you know they didn't have they had
like no noses they had like red eyes
they had like big ass [ __ ] mouths and
[ __ ] like that
then the story went like got even more
gruesome
where they started finding the bodies of
these missing people and like all the
blood was drained out
um also livestock was found with all the
blood drained out usually goats uh
sometimes other animals so that was
another thing that was uh very common um
so
then from that legend sprang another
legend and like i said on this show i
didn't really do any kind of like
cryptid type legends because we did a
whole couple shows about kryptids and
so i was like well i don't want to like
tread familiar ground so i try not to do
any cryptids but
uh the grunch people had kind of like an
offshoot legend like you know it's it's
an expanded universe
uh where
the grunch people got pissed off and
they decided to protect themselves they
were going to tell satan
to
give them like a monster to protect them
so the grunch road monster is born so
that's like another like an offshoot of
the original grunge people legend
um
so the i don't i'm just like the grunt
street the grunge grunch road monster
rather
he's kind of like i guess he's kind of
like goaty looking
and
so he's like on the street he's it's
what he does is he pretends to be like a
wounded baby goat
and he lays in the road being like help
me help me oh my god and then so you
slowed your car down
and then you get out
and then the monster goes like what and
like turn to this big like [ __ ] a grunch
like a big scary like goat looking [ __ ]
and like [ __ ] claws you and eats your
[ __ ] face so you know there's that
whole thing too um
also some of them have like
magic powers
too
it's like like a humanoid goat basically
and uh
but smart like a monkey uh some of them
say he has wings too like bat wings
because of course so it's almost kind of
like getting into jersey devil territory
i feel like at this point jason jumped
in jason wilder jumped and says we need
to show our [ __ ] norse mythology
maybe like
mesoamerican mythology we we should do
something like that i kind of felt like
we were thinking about doing that and i
don't remember that we ever got around
to it those are huge subjects though
we'd have to do like a show on they did
it i'd have to like narrow it down a
little bit two separate shows because
the mayan aztec mesoamerican stuff
oh man
that's like talking about catholicism
with all the angels and all the saints
and everything that would take forever
you have to do it piece by piece
norris mythology you could do like a
general overview
but even that one the idiots were you
know pretty complicated
i'm gonna run to the bathroom yeah go
ahead
i'm gonna go ahead and address the
comment section while jenny is uh using
the restroom here i'm using the facility
using the facilities let me go back and
see what everybody's talking about
okay
jason said the king arthur legends are
interesting with the merlin and the
dragon etc yeah
there's a lot of different interpret
there's a lot of different versions of
them you know la morte de arthur which
is you know the uh
uh the ones that were written out of
brittany which would be you know france
france nowadays you know they're pretty
good
and that's a bunch of uh britain's
in france talking about the good old
days back in the hockey motherland of
england and what they were doing
um of course none of this shit's
historical
um but
interesting writing i still to this day
have a real soft spot for [ __ ] the
movie excalibur from the i guess it was
late 70s
and um i have it on blu-ray i [ __ ]
love that movie
and that
[ __ ] wagner [ __ ] soundtrack in the
back [ __ ]
it just brings that [ __ ] inner
honking me out [ __ ] i'll be like oh
yeah i understand it just kind of
culturally
i don't know if it's genetics or what
just culturally kind of speaking to me
and in a weird way that same director
did zardoz
i gotta get that [ __ ] on blu-ray
if any if you if any of you subscribers
want to send me a [ __ ] gift send me
[ __ ] send me a blu-ray [ __ ] zardoz
before i buy that [ __ ] because i might
have to [ __ ] drop drop my nuts and
buy that but um no that'd be a great
gift get started
zardoz is kind of like a modern version
of
of excalibur
a lot of that kinda if you read a lot of
those [ __ ]
carnegie type
rockefeller foundation white papers
that's what they're talking about is
what you saw on zardoz hold on let me go
ahead and go to the rest of myself
that's all it is
on blu-ray man i want somebody to sing
again
i'll have to buy it
oh my god
slasher fred says one of the creepiest
urban myths is the babysitter and the
man upstairs i actually do want to talk
about that i was like
i was like i had so many like uh urban
legends that i picked out and i was just
kind of like i want to talk about like a
few classics i didn't know if i wanted
to go too much into them because i know
a lot of people have heard them like
specifically the babysitter the man
upstairs which has been in like tons of
movies and stuff
but i thought maybe it was still like
good to talk about him because you could
talk about like where
you know where it came from like how old
it was and stuff like that so i do have
like some classic ones that i want to
talk about too like i said i have a huge
list and
you know whether we get to all of them i
don't know but i just thought we could
probably like skip around and like talk
about
different [ __ ] but yeah i always like
really like that story and i'm
one of the most fascinating things
things to me about urban legends is like
the variations and i'm always kind of
interested to see
how a story
evolves because most urban legends
um
when they
you know they they seem to go in like
cycles so a lot of times like a
particular story will kind of like
proliferate like over a brief time
period like a few months or something
but then like and then it'll kind of go
latent for a while but then it'll pop up
in another version with like new details
added like in a new
you know location or something like that
and i find that really interesting and
i'm always kind of like wondering why
that happens
you know
so
i mean
it's like a massive [ __ ] topic and
it's all day to day and yesterday i was
just kind of like looking through all
this [ __ ] about urban legends looking
through all my urban legend books and
stuff and i was like oh i gotta i want
to talk about this one i want to talk
about that one and it's like now i just
have so many that i'm kind of like
i'm just kind of like holy [ __ ] i don't
even like know what i'm gonna do now but
uh another one i want to talk about too
and this is kind of like a more
recent one i guess although it maybe
kind of stems from some [ __ ] from the
90s and i was going to do a whole actual
show about this but then i thought we
were doing a show about urban legends i
was like well i'll just stick it in here
because i don't know like i said if it's
substantive enough for like a whole
entire show on its own and that is the
whole uh black-eyed children
uh legend i walked in and she said
black-eyed children and all of a sudden
i'm thinking about black-eyed peas i got
a whole bunch of dried
black-eyed peas thinking about yeah
also they got hungry
well all we've eaten today is a single
hamburger losing weight
so i mean we can we can eat after the
show i don't know i don't know what we
have in there but you have to what's up
hi pookie
there any urban legends about you trying
to lose some of this damn fat man
getting [ __ ] better and better as i
go
tyler says beast of bray road is right
down the road for me yeah like i said we
um we talked about the beast of bray
road i'm pretty sure like on one of our
cryptid shows so
i wanted to stay away from cryptids
largely because i know like there's a
ton of [ __ ] urban legends about
cryptids but
i kind of feel like that's its own
category so i kind of wanted to go more
with like [ __ ]
i don't know just like a bunch of people
in there suggesting like a couple months
of mythology
yeah
i mean we should probably do that that
would be really interesting look at
pookie's on the show
look at that baby she's like stab it
that bit okay i like how she just like
you kiss her on the head and she just
shuts up she just puts up but she's like
okay she likes it i will accept some
affection from you
she's like yep scratch it scratch it
look at her face
yeah it's okay are you being good
she is being good yep yeah look at that
look she gets daddy
tammy says there's a good channel on
youtube called mythology and fiction
explained ooh i'm gonna have to check
that out i really like the one oh [ __ ]
man what's it called overly sarcastic
productions and they do uh mythology and
history like but funny and it's kind of
like animated and they're really funny
as well it's like it's like a girl and a
guy
jason volley says oh kitty
cute cat yeah she is the cutest yeah
she's like a little monkey
very smart she can pick things up with
her hand and throw them
chases her own toys
she's gonna make my own fun she's
begging for those little meat sticks and
every time i give her one she would need
it
[Laughter]
she's like i'm saving it for later well
she knows he keeps them in the in the
drawer like in the uh the what what you
call it the bedside table yeah and she
knows they're in there so she just like
waddles over and then like she sits and
stares at him and she'll give me one of
those and then stares at the drawer and
then stares at him
and she goes okay and then she goes give
me another one
i might eat it later yeah
so let's talk about black-eyed children
for a moment
so a bunch of these stories
uh
no one knows entirely where this came
from the earliest
reported sighting like written down was
from 1996.
now i kind of feel like this
really took off in the internet era
because there's tons and tons of stories
about black eyed kids on
no sleep and creepypasta and stuff like
that but
the first story and this story is about
this might have been circulating before
this but the first one that was kind of
like written down was from 1996. so
there was a guy named brian bethel he
was a journalist and he was from abilene
texas
now he wrote this report i don't know if
he published it in the paper i don't
know what the [ __ ] he did but he wrote
it down somewhere and it was published
somewhere
he says that he was out late one night
in his car
and he had either just come out of the
movies or he pulled into a movie theater
parking lot because he had to write a
check because it was 1996 y'all
they didn't have this whole take a
picture of the check and you know do it
you know put it in your bag
uh so he's gonna write a check and he's
sitting in the car and he's not really
paying attention to what's going on
uh but meanwhile two young boys
come up to his car
and then tap on the window like driver's
side window
and so he rolls the window down and he
says immediately he felt like really
really freaked out like and he couldn't
really figure out why because they were
just like two kids right it was like two
boys
now the older kid says uh hey me and my
brother want to watch a movie but we
forgot our money at home can you give us
a ride back to our house
um you know we don't live that far away
uh you know we don't have a gun or
anything so they said like some weird
[ __ ] like that so
the dude driving the car is just like
man this is like sketch as [ __ ] i don't
even know if i want to like deal with
this right now and he's like look even
if i took you to your house and brought
you back here like the movie would be
[ __ ] over before you even got here so
what's the [ __ ] point
and
uh he said that
basically he like look and he started
getting really freaked out so he like
kind of like looked away from them and
then when he looked back at him he
noticed that their eyes were all
completely black you know what i mean
so at that point he was just like yeah
[ __ ] that noise and he [ __ ] uh took
off right
so uh he's like you know kept this up
now this was the first
written
account of these black eyed children but
since then this story is like really
proliferated and what usually happens
these kids they usually look like normal
kids uh usually aged between 6 and 16
years old
um but their eyes are completely black
although most people don't notice that
at first
and almost always they like approach a
car in a parking lot or they come to
your house and knock on your door
and ask you to be invited inside uh so
they're either doing that or if they
like knock on your car window they're
like looking for a ride and i'm not
entirely sure because i haven't read all
the black-eyed children stories but it's
like i don't actually know what happens
if you actually do give them a ride or
if you actually let them inside your
house because most of the stories just
seem to be like yeah these kids came to
my house and wanted to come inside they
have black eyes so i said [ __ ] no which
you know he would
so i don't know like what exactly
happens if you do let them in but
they're always trying to get like lit
like vampires i guess they're always
trying to get like invited inside so
that's kind of their whole thing like
whether it's inside your car or whatever
and story goes that
they are much more likely to
approach you
if you already know about them so sorry
i just like cursed everybody by telling
them
now that black eyed children are gonna
come to your [ __ ] door and then
you'll see what happens
um so let me talk about a few kind of
like classic ones because
uh slasher fred also brought up serial
kill in the back seat which was another
one that i wanted to
talk about
because as i said i know a lot of people
have heard some of the classic ones but
i find them interesting just in the
variations of them and like where they
might have come from
so let's talk about probably one of
those i didn't really want to talk about
the hook because i feel like that's like
everybody knows that story right yeah
with the whole you know we're making it
we're making out in the car and then
yeah i mean i was a little kid that [ __ ]
was old yeah i heard that one as a very
little kid yeah and we've seen like
variations of it in like tons of money
that's like the story that my little
[ __ ] babysitter kimmy would tell me
well she wouldn't tell me she'd be
telling our little friends
yeah yes but when i that's back when i
was the pookie
i'd be like back with tom what's the
point i used to be the pookie
you don't get to be a pooper
you're too
i'd be like six and [ __ ] kimmy my
baby said he'd be holding she's like 14.
and [ __ ] you know they'd be listening
to the led zeppelin albums over her
house and [ __ ] she talked to all her
friends and they tell stories like that
i look back and they're going whoa
man i used to love you you take him i
used to love the hook story yeah yeah
yeah i mean it's so gruesome i [ __ ]
love it yeah you know what i mean i
because honestly ever since i was ever
since i can remember yeah um i was into
creepy [ __ ] like if somebody was telling
some scary stories i was sitting right
plopping myself right down and like
listening to that [ __ ] i didn't care if
it gave me nightmares or not i love
creepy [ __ ] always have it's it's a
genetic predisposition
so that's i i think that's why i'm
always like so interested in these kind
of things like and
like i said the cool thing about urban
legends is that yeah most of the time it
didn't happen
but
a lot of them are just plausible enough
that it might have happened somewhere
um
but it probably didn't happen like the
way that the story's told but some of
them are actually based on real things
one of the things that i was gonna say
and he talks about this in uh in this
book that i had he talks about that in
here
there is a urban legend uh that went
around back in the late 80s and early
90s it might have gone around a few
times since then
about a person
that was out in the desert i think it
was in arizona or new mexico or
somewhere and they were shooting at one
of those big like saguaro cactuses yeah
and
uh
they shot it and it fell on them
and it was just kind of you know it was
just kind of like it's i think the
legend is called revenge of the plant or
something like that
and the funny thing about that like uh
jan bronban was talking about this in
his book and he's like guess what
this actually did happen this is based
on a true story uh the details of it
changed as it got retold but he's like
it actually did happen i think it was in
arizona there was a dude and his friend
and they were out like just [ __ ]
around with their shotguns or whatever
and they were shooting out in the desert
and one of the guys did shoot at like a
26-foot saguaro cactus and it fell on
him and killed him
and it's like it was funny because it
that legend like proliferate because i
guess it's such a ridiculous i mean it's
sad that that dude died but it's just
such a ridiculous way to die
that it essentially became an urban
legend that was even like a song about
it like somebody wrote like a like a
[ __ ] funny country folk song about it
and but he's like no it actually really
did happen it's like somebody out there
so some of them actually do have some
basis in truth some of them actually are
based on a real thing that happened
i think some of those ufo [ __ ]
stories are also based on something that
actually really really did happen
there's one i don't remember what the
name of the [ __ ] case was
but the guy [ __ ] described seeing a
damn alien monster and they drew it what
it looked like
when you look at it you go like man it's
an owl
oh i remember that one yeah what was the
name it's like do you not know what an
owl yeah
and if you don't believe me you can go
on you can go on youtube and and look at
some bizarre ass owls they got some owls
you look at that that would scare you if
you saw it big i mean if you weren't
expecting because some of them are very
large yeah and the feathers and
everything the way they're shaped they
don't even look real look like something
out of damn movie i i saw i was looking
at one owl i didn't know how it could
look like that
and it's like three feet four feet tall
yeah summer like ridiculous big yeah and
it just i was like man i never seen an
owl like that
well you know how a lot of saw that in
the dark on a flashlight that might
scare the [ __ ] out of you yeah
especially if it was going really fast
you weren't expecting to see anything
and you didn't get that greater look at
it yeah um that's where i honestly
that's where i think the mothman [ __ ]
came from i think that was like a big
ass owl well in that one case i'm
talking about it wasn't flying it was
[ __ ] stand still in a tree
yeah and i've seen separate even in
florida i've seen some pretty big ass
owls like just sitting in a tree yeah
you know what i mean and i knew it was
an owl because i you know it was sitting
there so i saw it but if you were out
walking in the dark and something just
flew at you and you didn't really get
that good look at it and it was [ __ ]
gigantic
down here i wouldn't be alarmed because
i would figure it's probably an owl or a
[ __ ] sandhill crane because those
[ __ ] things are massive also
but you know
slasher fred says the original twilight
zone had some episodes inspired by urban
myths yep that's true like the episode
called 22 in which a woman has a
recurring dream in which a nurse leads
her to the morgue oh yeah i remember
that one i used to really like that one
actually
uh danny rowling goes face says awesome
show topic tonight thank you
uh larry martin says from what i've
heard on black-eyed children is if you
let them in you'll get sick and probably
die within a couple weeks i figured it
was something like that i didn't know if
it was like some kind of like death
portent or something like that slasher
fred also says or the episode the grave
in which a guy spends the night at the
cemetery and honestly one of the most
common urban legends which i'd ever
write down
i first heard it
as a very little kid i had a
book called
the thing at the foot of the bed
somebody gave it to me when i was little
like in a set of books but like why a
books
and it was a compilation of
urban legends like creepy poems um
creepy
uh tips about ghosts like [ __ ] not to do
about ghosts or what to do if you wanted
to see ghosts like look between a dog's
ears and things like that so they're all
kind of like tips like that and
one of the stories in there was the
classic story where
you know somebody is either at a slumber
party their pub or whatever the you know
there's different versions of it and
some [ __ ] in town that everybody
hated
uh had died recently and been buried in
the cemetery
and so people are either at the slumber
party or at the pub or whatever and
they're getting kind of like all riled
up and somebody dares somebody else hey
go to the graveyard and go sit on that
dude's grave because the story goes that
he'll like reach up and grab you because
he was such an [ __ ] when he was uh
alive
so they're like well to prove that
you've been there you have to like stick
something into the girl like a knife or
whatever
and so the person goes
to the grave and they're kind of
freaking out and they stick the grave
and then like it kind of switches to the
other people and so the other people
like oh man that person never came back
from the cemetery so they go to the
cemetery the next day and they find that
the person
uh is dead on the gr like laying across
the grave because what happened was that
when they stuck the knife into the grave
they stuck it through their own sleeve
or coat tail or something like that and
they perceived that the corpse had
grabbed them and they died of fight
which is that even possible can you die
a fright
um they say you can i'm not sure i'm not
really sure
i mean i guess you could
you'd have to be really [ __ ] scared
to like [ __ ] die from that yeah but
that's a very common and i've seen other
variations i've seen other variations
actually they did a movie
on mst
from
the 40s or 50s called ring of terror
and it was similar it didn't have
anything to do with the graveyard but it
was a bunch of medical students and the
dare was you had to go and take this
ring off this corpse
you know for as a
hazing
and
something happened like they went in
there like to take the fit and somebody
like it
seemed like it grabbed them or the hand
kind of went like that and the person
died of freight so this is a very very
common urban legend like i said this the
book that i had that had that story in
it
was from the early 70s and i think this
story was old even then because i'd seen
variations of it like i said ring of
terror had a variation of it and that
was came out maybe the early 50s i want
to say
um again not a graveyard but similar
thing where you know you got dared to
like go take something off a
dead body and then thought that it
grabbed you
so that's a very very common story it's
very very old
um
yeah there's also the urban tale about
alligators living in sewers actually
harlan ellison wrote a great story about
that called croatian about alligators in
the sewers i kind of that was going
around in the 80s i remember hearing
that as a kid i don't think enough food
that's what i mean it's it's not
plausible if you think about it i mean
yes there was kind of like a thing uh
where people would get baby alligators
for
pets because they did actually used to
sell them in pet stores i do remember
that
but because they are cute when they're
babies
but uh you know decidedly less cute when
they get larger also they could eat you
used to be able to buy alligators as
little babies the size of a lizard out
of comic books
back in the 60s
which is crazy yeah well they didn't
expect things to live long so they
forgot the kids won't feed it it won't
make but you know they'll die
because you know they were everywhere
yeah they were bred in a little in
captivity anyway people trying to make
damn money on them
um but now they get pretty big flush
them down a toilet they survive it
they can get in the sewer
they wouldn't live long no it's too cold
down there alligators uh i don't know if
you guys know but alligators one there's
no food and two
i mean other may be rats but uh two uh
alligators like
warm environments yep and they would
have to be they're gonna want to be in
the sunlight if anything they would try
to follow try to go downstream as much
as possible
until they eventually
got out
maybe they'd go out to the ocean but
they'd probably end up in a processing
plant
and be killed there
they wouldn't survive it i kind of feel
like i mean baby alligators are small
but they're not small enough that you
could like easily flush them down your
toilet just gonna say well no some of
them are the size of a [ __ ] lizard a
lizard but like i said the story went
that once they got too big yeah then the
people would flush them like that once
they got too big then they're not gonna
push down the [ __ ] door that's true
i mean you could maybe you could maybe
flush like a a lizard-sized alley like a
really baby baby alligator down the
toilet without blocking it up although i
wouldn't trust it not to block it out
and they might survive it in a big city
it's possible they can hold their breath
for a [ __ ] half hour again that's the
thing but the story is that all of these
you know there was a proliferation of
baby alligators that all got flushed
down toilets and now there's like a
whole
you know little
community of them like living down in
the sewers no way no food no way there's
no way that could happen no food well
it's just kind of like we've talked
about this you know having to do with
some [ __ ] like a tropical animal yeah
it's the same kind of thing when you
talk about like the [ __ ] loch ness
monster and [ __ ] like that it's just
kind of like the environment doesn't
support would not support it
if you flush one down
and it was small and it survived it
which it probably would they can hold
their breath for about an hour
we'd end up in a sewer it would try to
go downstream
it would end up in some kind of kind of
sewage processing plant where it would
be separated and it would end up
probably in a bunch of sludge
and we try to get out
and it probably wouldn't be able to
there's little pools and [ __ ]
of it they're trying to process it and
then they'd filter some of it the good
water and [ __ ] there might be some
runoff places where they
where it would [ __ ]
i think in some places there's some
sludge
plants where they pump it out into open
fields where it dries
they would probably end up on that side
which would mean that they would end up
in basically a garbage dump
then maybe they could survive that and
walk to a place where there was fresh
water but it would immediately become a
wild alligator again it wouldn't be in
the
sewer
there's no reason for it to be in a
sewer yeah why would it stay there
probably just try to get out it would
get out it would immediately try to get
out and it probably it might be able to
get out depending where where it was if
you're talking about up north no die the
first winter
that's what i'm saying because i kind of
feel like the alligators in the sewers
smith was mainly based in like really
urban areas like new york city and i'm
like there's no way that they would
survive down there so it's cold up there
yeah they like warm weather honestly
reptiles of any kind
when it gets cold they go into like
stasis yep you know so they don't like
move around and [ __ ] they would die the
first winter i've had pet lizards
it goes under
85 degrees
they just sit there
they don't move they have to go through
a cold spell they'd have to have a bunch
of calories to make it
and they wouldn't that wouldn't have
happened up north and no alligators
can't survive up north they die
jason wooley says uh
the alligator film was great when they
flush it down the toilet and then john
gore says alligator scared the hell out
of me as a child me too um honestly i
haven't seen those gotta see you yeah
it's i haven't seen it many years but
when i saw it as a kid it scared the
[ __ ] crap out of me well alligators
are scary and the thing about it is that
you know i grew up in florida and
we have gators and we have sharks
so
watching a horror movie about gators or
sharks that's not far-fetched i'm like
that could totally happen to me and that
is very scary i was never scared of them
once it got to about 10 11 12 years old
it wasn't scared of them
i mean
in mississippi there were already
there's a known fact that some people
kept them in their house
down in louisiana
where you have like a doggy door
where the alligator could get out these
are people live on a [ __ ] p road you
know out of bio
and [ __ ] the alligator will sleep
inside during the night the day time it
leaves
they had people that raised them like
dogs
that come in [ __ ]
they don't even feed the alligator just
the alligator was well they fed them
when they were babies
but then when they got big the alligator
comes in the house to sleep
and then every day it leaves through
basically a doggy door on the floor
and goes out into the [ __ ] bayou and
[ __ ] does what an alligator does
then at night when the sun starts going
down they'll come in the house and sleep
they got the [ __ ] recorded it would be
on film i've seen it before
but you know
if you raise the alligator
they can be docile towards the person
that raises them
you can't do that with a wild one
but uh yeah they've had people that have
missed pets
that we're not talking a little
alligator we're talking ten foot
ten nowadays it probably fourteen
sixteen feet
because that was 80s that they were
doing that and they'd still be alive
alligators live a long time
an alligator can live to be a hundred
easy
just they tend not to they tend to die
before they can get bigger and bigger as
they go
have been some reports i don't know if
it's true but guys flying over to by you
[ __ ] look down
and see that [ __ ] huge alligator that
they estimated
it's a supposedly serious result
serious reports
and they were estimating from the sky
that that alligator was 20 something
feet long
which would mean you're talking 150
year old alligator
which i wouldn't doubt it
the problem is is that once an alligator
gets that size you it has a large
caloric
requirement
so there'd have to be a lot of food
which i guess there is
but the bigger an alligator gets the
more of a target it becomes i don't
think something like that could hide for
long
somebody would see it
you know and go after it and try to kill
it go look at the size of this thing
hugo says best gator movie
well i mean alligator was a good one uh
some people have mentioned lake placid
which is also very good
um
jason willie says rogue which is another
that's one that i've been wanting to
watch actually because that's been
recommended to me that's actually a
crocodile movie uh i think lake placid
was crocodiles too now that i'm thinking
about it
so i don't know i haven't seen that many
alligator movies to be honest with you
other than alligator all the other ones
were crocodiles it was funny you know
when i would [ __ ] go to louisiana
when i was a little kid back in the 70s
and early 80s
because you know my cousins are cajun
and um
they weren't worried about alligator
they're worried about gar
which is we call it alligator gar
it's a fish with looks like a head it's
more like an eel
very primitive fish
with the head that looks kind of like an
alligator a big long snout filled with
[ __ ]
needle sharp teeth
and they can get pretty big
and uh
they were trying to wipe them out during
the 20s with electric with paddle boats
that had this electric apparatus that
was supposedly electrocuted guys are
trying to make money doing that
doing a public service getting rid of
gar
they thought they were [ __ ] dangerous
i don't think they were the
in modern times divers have gone down in
there and tried to interact with them
and they're not hostile
[ __ ] scary looking though and
i remember as a kid they were mostly
afraid of those could we be swimming
afraid you get attacked by gar alligator
gar yeah i remember this we had those
here too yeah we assumed they were
[ __ ] like a shark
but when you look at him you see what
i'm talking about
but as a kid i remember fishing
and
fishing out there and you see him hit
the water in the back of that car
rolling over
like that some of those things had been
10 12 feet long
huge huge
back in the 70s
i don't know if they're still out there
that big but they were big back then
you could tell when it hit your bait
they wouldn't hit and [ __ ] struggle
like a bass or anything else they would
just hit it and take it and run with it
slow and you're like it's just a long
steady pressure and then pull it on the
line you couldn't find them it would
just break
it was weird
yeah did your imagination run wild with
you how big that was
but i think they were probably 10 to 12
feet long
maybe 80 pounds
maybe 100 i don't know
just look like something from a
prehistoric era
yeah a couple people brought up uh crawl
yeah we saw that in the theater that was
actually pretty good that was an
alligator movie
uh so
yeah we saw it in the theater didn't we
yeah i just said that yeah yeah
it was crawl too wasn't it no was it was
crawl one yeah it was the first one but
they had mcconaughey in it right
what are you talking about we saw one in
the goddamn theater about alligators
yeah matthew mcconaughey wasn't in there
that wasn't matthew
who was that that was in that
i don't remember who was in it but it
wasn't matthew mcconaughey
i think sam raimi produced it
yes matthew mcconaughey
and there was there was underneath the
house maybe he was in it but i don't
remember matthew mcconaughey it might
have been i don't know but yeah it was
about alligators yeah but it wasn't part
two the one that we saw that you're
thinking of was the shark one 47 meters
down yeah that was part two that we saw
in the theater
uh we were talking about dying a fright
sheila ann said yes my friend's mom's
little sister a dog chased her i mean
this was the 20s but that's what they
said she died from the 70s
so maybe
like i said doesn't sound that
implausible slasher fred says there's
the bloody mary tale which was the
inspiration for many horror movies
including the 1992 classic candyman uh
then starbucks 78 says it's cold night
for alligators which is referring to the
rocky erickson song i'm presuming
um
nonfornix says i was always curious when
the bloody mary story started my sister
knows of it but no one older than us
seems to know anything about it but i
don't well okay i don't know how old you
guys are but when i was a kid
uh the bloody mary [ __ ] was all the rage
everyone's you know you had slumber
parties yeah and you i mean you kind of
had to do that you not only you had to
do the bloody mary thing and you also
had to do the light as a feather stiff
as a board you're raising raising people
love people often yeah like in the craft
uh i saw it work one time okay sort of
we didn't like they weren't flying or
nothing like that but it was like it did
she did come like a couple feet off the
floor okay okay so it did work one time
the bloody mary thing um but i never had
that work though obviously
as a teenager in brazil brazil also had
the bloody mary myth
so i don't know where it came from but
they had it too in brazil i think that's
been around a long time yeah and that's
[ __ ] on the other side of the equator
south america it's crazy how some of
these stories
like you compare ones to with you know
different cultures and stuff like that a
lot more really really similar yeah i
kind of feel like most cultures have
something like that where it's kind of
even if it's not called bloody mary
where you go in a dark bathroom and you
say somebody's name in the mirror
however many times and then they come in
and eat your face or whatever in brazil
it was bloody mary same thing yeah so
somehow and it was bloody and honestly
like i said there's you know candyman
obviously is the most obvious thing that
took off you know that uh played on that
but i mean when i was a kid it was
bloody mary but i know that there's
different variations we saw a great
brazilian horror movie i was just gonna
say that yeah yeah yeah that was recent
a couple years ago yeah and i think it
was called bloody mary versus something
or what's that called yeah it was like a
bunch of ghost hunters and that was yeah
they were fighting like the the ghost
that came out of the mirror over the
past couple years
um we've been
watching some brazilian horror movies
that are very much like classic american
horror movies from the 80s and 90s i
recommend them
um we've seen like three of them in the
past couple years they were all great
yeah funny
funny [ __ ] it's kind of like evil dead
type funny ghost killers versus bloody
marion yeah but it was
something like that something like that
that was good i think it was on shutter
it was a ripoff of ghostbusters and they
they're having fun that but way gory
yeah they know it was super gory yeah
it's like a mix it was like a mash-up of
all the american horror stuff all
together in a brazilian story
funniest [ __ ]
uh see it subtitled
don't don't see it don't don't see it
dub see a subtitle well i mean i
recommend that for any foreign movie
don't ever watch the day the acting was
good [ __ ] the humor was real good it
had a lot real gory and then there was
another brazilian one about the [ __ ]
remember that demon
yeah
and they were homage in seventies horror
brazilian seventies or it was kind of
like italian seventies or they were
homage in that too and that guy kept
coming up remember that he was like
he got transformed into that weird
[ __ ]
machete wielding demon that was a good
one too but i forgot what was going on
yeah what yeah what the [ __ ] was the
name of that one no i can't remember we
did review it though i'd have to like
look back because we were reviewing so
many movies i can't remember yeah
brazilians know horror they grew up with
the same horror movies that we do
see that's the cool thing the cool thing
about horror yeah just like the cool
thing about urban legends which is what
a horror is based on our religions is
that
we all it's it's very like um
it's it's very unifying yeah because
because humans everywhere kind of like
have similar fears yeah uh so and so it
comes out in slightly different ways
depending on what the culture is but you
know if you dig into it they're like
very very simple yeah and brazilian
generation x is like american generation
x they [ __ ] listen to the same heavy
metal [ __ ] bands and [ __ ] and they'll
be riffing on iron maiden and stuff
during the middle of the band because
they watched that they were listening to
that too so it's just brazilian horror
is real good the modern stuff
the old stuff wasn't that good but
yeah past couple years yeah i've seen
some really good like brazilian horror
yeah
uh slasher friend says if you guys ever
see that 80s classic three men and a
baby there's an urban myth in which
there's a ghost of a murdered boy yeah
i've heard that one too um now
officially the story is that it wasn't a
person in the background it was like a
cardboard cutout that of somebody that
that got left in the shot or something
like that there's like also a similar
myth about the wizard of oz
where there's supposedly
um a shot where you can see
a dwarf that hanged himself
which didn't really happen but
and you can kind of see it in the
background so that's like another common
urban legend that goes around about the
wizard of oz but you know what i mean uh
victor says hey i made it only two and
two hours and nine minutes late yeah
just kidding we haven't even honestly
i've only talked about like two or three
legends at this point and i have like so
many but um you know uh john gore said i
was raised catholic i wouldn't mess with
that bloody mary stuff honestly like i
don't believe in any of that kind of
stuff but
when you're at i mean when you're a kid
and you're at a slumber party that's
what it was and slumber parties
you know it's always kind of like well
it's like why tempt fate you know what i
mean
it's kind of like you know it's probably
not nothing's going to happen it's just
kind of like another urban legend that i
was um
that i saw online that came up a lot
is uh this legend of this thing called
the black angel which is like it's in
this cemetery in iowa city i think
and it's this it's all kind of like
oxified so it's an angel and it's kind
of like looking down like that it's a
grave and it's all black
and story goes that pregnant ladies if
they walk underneath it they'll have a
miscarriage or
if you touch the statue then you'll die
within six months
um and i kind of feel like
even mo even people that don't believe
in that kind of stuff i always kind of
feel like you'll probably think about
nah
i mean why risk it you know what i mean
you never know i probably i you know i i
wouldn't think anything bad would happen
but even i would probably think about it
for a second like nah i'm just i'm not
gonna i don't need to touch that
you know i'm just saying
so i kind of feel like everybody has
that little bit of
a little bit of doubt in there which
which like i said that's why like urban
legends proliferate so much
so let's kind of talk about some
kind of classic legends so we'll talk
about
if you've heard versions of this or what
versions you've heard because there's
like these ones are have been around for
so long that there's like a lot of
different variations
so one of the ones i want to talk about
was the vanishing hitchhiker story now
jan bren van wrote it might have been
his first or second book and it was
called the vanishing hitchhiker because
other than the hook i feel like this is
probably like one of the most popular at
least american like urban legends
now the version that i heard when i was
a kid i don't remember who i heard it
from
version that i heard
was
you know it's usually a dude and he's by
himself and he's out driving on some
remote uh you know road at night
and he usually it's it's usually like a
young woman he sees a young woman by the
side of the road that looks like she
needs help uh sometimes
the version i heard she looked like she
was wearing like a prom dress or some
[ __ ] like that like she looked like
she'd been
out to some fancy do or whatever
um and the weather's kind of cold so he
picks her up and she's like real
appreciative and everything and
most versions i heard uh he gives her a
coat because it's cold outside and she
doesn't have one
and then she tells him to go to this
particular house hey drop me off here
and so he does but when he pulls up in
front of the house and turns around to
say hey here we are
she's gone
uh now in some versions of the story
uh he investigates so he actually goes
up to the house and said hey is she here
blah blah blah
and they say oh well yeah that's our
daughter because you know he describes
her and they're like yeah that's our
daughter she died a year ago it's
usually like an anniversary uh she died
a year ago like in a car accident like
right where he picked her up or
something like that um you know so
that's a very common uh iteration of the
story i've also seen other versions
where
if he gave the girl a coat like
sometimes he goes to the cemetery and
then like the coat is like draped over
her grave i've seen that one as well
thank you victor
uh have some money well thank you we
will
they giving that money yeah handing out
money thank you very much victor is
hanging out handing out money handing it
out to this
p and jenny jenny
[Laughter]
slasher fred says there's an urban myth
in which a man dressed as santa claus
climbed down the chimney and died which
was used in gremlins yeah that's right
um although that might have been based
on a real thing because there was
actually it wasn't anybody dressed like
santa claus but it was actually a
teenager
i can't remember when it happened no no
it was after
was that a reason
it's happened more than once i think and
he was trying to get back into his house
like he was sneaking back into the house
okay there's another one where there was
a teenager trying to
break into a house
that was unoccupied
uh but everything there was stuff in it
and he tried to shimmy down the chimney
and got stuck died in there
and they didn't find him until seven or
eight years later his body had been up
there the house got sold purchased by
somebody else
and there was an obstruction in the
chimney and they checked and that there
was that missing kid can you imagine
holy crap yeah like well hey
don't go straight down dumbasses there's
[ __ ] turns in them and [ __ ] valve
type things to shut the plenums and
sometimes they get narrower don't jump
down so just pro tip don't try to like
break into somebody's house by going
against the children break the glass
it's not going to work out the way you
break the glass and go through the
window much easier yeah thank you bryce
uh
from new zealand all the way from new
zealand damn thank you 10 new zealand
dollars top quality content thank you
always good subjects love the different
views both of you bring thank you very
much that's very nice of you
yeah
uh but yeah so so that's again that is
an urban legend because uh so many
different versions of it have been told
but that actually did happen
a few times like in real life i can't
remember the year that the one i'm
thinking of it was a teenage boy
and he i think he was trying to get back
into his own house because he's trying
to sneak back in because he wasn't
supposed to be out or something like
that
and uh he then like obviously he went
missing and like his family freaked out
and i don't think they ever found out
what happened to him because i think
that somebody else had bought the house
and then they found the body in there it
was like a skeleton so it has happened
in real life but okay so it's happened
more than once
yeah i think yeah like i said it's you
know i can't remember enough probably
like propagating yet another version of
an urban legend now by just saying
because i don't remember the details
weird fact you guys can look at it up on
youtube just look at the urban
exploration there are many many
abandoned houses and places of business
in remote areas of the united states
that are just left untouched
sometimes for decades
like you can find an old abandoned
[ __ ] ski resort out in the middle of
nowhere fully [ __ ]
outfitted and walk into it and nobody's
been in there in 10 15 years weird same
thing with houses
vacation houses
fully [ __ ]
furnished
somebody's personal property in there
he'll die no relatives to give it to and
it just sits there
weird
sometimes with cars out in the parking
lot
it just becomes the state gets it but
then the state doesn't know what to do
with it so it just sits there
and sometimes classic cars like
corvettes and [ __ ] tammy said didn't
anyone smell the body see that's what i
always want about these
that's one thing about all of these kind
of stories like a body that's been in a
house for a really long time i kind of
feel like there's gonna be a window of
time yeah uh where it's gonna smell like
a dead body yeah i mean that's a very
distinctive smell about a month uh and
most people would be like hey there's a
[ __ ] dead body up in this in the case
that i heard about he was stuck in a
chimney during the during a time when
the [ __ ] house was abandoned
nobody owned it
and which like i said that would make it
alone nobody owned it for a long period
of time because i'd like to think that
if somebody crawled up in my attic or
something like that and died i think
that i would smell that [ __ ] yeah just
saying and i would be like yeah
something's dead up there might need to
check that out
i mean you might think it was an animal
or something like that but you would
definitely know something was wrong i
mean that is a very distinctive smell
so
yeah i i do kind of feel like the one
and like i said i can't remember all the
details i do remember it being a teenage
boy
and i thought that it was his own house
maybe he maybe he was breaking into a
house and nobody was in there but i
don't know but i thought it was his own
the one that i know it was uh it was a
house that was furnished but abandoned
he was trying to gain access to it and
got and it got stuck
was left in there for years
he was
missing eventually somebody bought the
house during the refurbishment
then they
tried to use the
somehow they knew that there was a dem
obstruction in the
fireplace in the chimney that's when
they found him
and i think it was
five to ten years
you guys can go and search that [ __ ] on
the internet and get back with me
dropping it victor says the doctor that
died in the chimney was in 2010 in
bakersfield california okay
okay this is a teenage guy that i was
talking about yeah i remember hearing
one about a teenage boy too right it
sounded like he tried to get into a
house that was abandoned but furnished
probably just to see what was in there
and use it for a hangout maybe take his
girlfriends in there maybe [ __ ] smoke
some smoke some weed type of deal he
didn't want to damage the house he's
just trying to gain access got stuck in
a chimney never found
so which man that be it never found any
way to go yeah
no thank you
uh but yeah so
yeah mary connolly said there was a
single woman wearing a leather jacket uh
went out but died in her garage her
bills were set on automatic she had a
large account due to inheritance she was
in the car park for 10 years yeah i have
heard of that happening i mean and i
think we talked about the other day like
somebody that was that lived alone and
they like fell behind their wardrobe or
something like that and broke their neck
and like died back there and it was like
years before anyone found them because
no one thought to look for them and the
cats starved to death or [ __ ] try to
[ __ ] thirst they found the cats dead
up in the windowsills trying to get out
that that upsets me more than like
[ __ ]
oh there was another one where uh
woman in an apartment [ __ ] died in
front of the television set while i was
playing and she sat there mummified
yeah several years i thought yeah
with the television going i think it was
two years somebody said last time you
told that story right and her rent was
being paid she had some kind of
automatic deposit going and the
electricity was being paid but
they eventually had to
gain access to the apartment and found
her mummified corp sitting there
watching television died of a heart
attack
well like i said she didn't she didn't
know no so
more upsetting for the people that had a
spider wrapped up in a blanket watching
tv
[ __ ]
but yeah so uh vanishing hitchhiker
story um even though i've actually seen
variations of the vanishing hitchhiker
story turn up on like unsolved mysteries
as like a real
thing
um
even into the 80s
but this story is very old according to
yon brunvand uh there are versions of it
going back to the 1870s
and they actually have uh
versions of this story pretty much all
over the world uh there's a bunch from
asia uh there's even like different
[ __ ] there's a mormon version there's
all kind of different stuff and there's
even there's another sub version where
like uh you know a different version
where
it's not necessarily good because mostly
the most common version that i've heard
was it's almost always a dude driving
the car and it's almost always a girl
that he picks up
um and the girl is usually had usually
been killed in a car accident at the
very place that he picked her up and
then however like some way he finds out
that she died like either by going back
to the house the address that she gave
him to return something that she left in
his car or going to the cemetery where
she's buried and seeing his coat like
draped over the gravestone that was the
most common versions that i heard but
there are other versions where
um the person that gets picked up by the
you know person picking up the
hitchhiker is
like a god or a goddess in disguise like
in hawaii there's a version where it's
pele you know like the volcano goddess
type situation and she's like testing
people out like to see if they're like
good samaritans or whatever and so they
but she just looks like a normal person
and then you pick her up and then like
after you like drop her off she's like
shazam i'm [ __ ] i'm pele like really
so there's that version too and i said
well i kind of feel like that is a kind
of a biblical story sort of isn't it
in there a kind of a story where jesus
pulled some [ __ ] like that
not hitchhiking obviously but there were
a lot of different jesus stories that
got omitted from the new testament i
kind of feel like there was a jesus
story or two that was similar to that
though where he was like pretending
oh look i'm just like such a like he's
trying to get somebody to help him out
and then he's like
you know
i don't know it's like candid camera
yeah sounds like something guess what
i'm jesus
it sounds like you win
sounds like something extra canonical
that probably would have been in there
probably well yeah that's probably like
a later one i'm just saying so
but even so so it seems like variations
of this story like particularly ones
where the hitchhiker turns out to be
somebody like
supernatural like a goddess or something
uh that seems to be like go
go back like thousands of years because
it's roman
the romans did that [ __ ] yeah so the gre
so the greeks they came up with stories
like that
the gods were in
disguise
like testing you yeah
well [ __ ] man [ __ ]
zeus or jupiter would disguise himself
as a bull and try and get some [ __ ]
he disguised himself as all kind of
things because we all know that women
just [ __ ] love that damn bull dick i
know every time i see a bull i just want
to jump on that yeah i know so they're
like [ __ ] good job zeus
okay well how about a shower of gold i
mean that's good too swan how about that
maybe swan i did all that yeah that's
why i was making that joke
you know he's just trying different [ __ ]
that's some penis envy right there
where you have men
coming up with religious stories that
says hey you know what don't tell nobody
but zeus
he's showing up dressed as a bull and
[ __ ] hitting our women
really he goes yeah [ __ ]
[Laughter]
damn how are we going to compete with
that i wish i thought it was like yeah
that's what that's what that's all about
that's [ __ ] hilarious
can't compete with that [ __ ] although it
kind of makes me laugh that like zeus is
actually like approaching women
in all these animal forms and the women
are like oh okay
i guess to the [ __ ] room to to the
[ __ ] greek male and the romans they
thought women were degenerate yeah and
they would just sleep with anything that
had a baby i think that's not degeneracy
is what it is
what it is is that they're imagining
that the power the sexual power of these
animals might be better than them so
it's penis envy against animals
well it's insecurity it is what it is so
they're always kind of like well we're
yeah we're worried that an animal might
have like might be better than us but
yeah yeah which is hilarious
[ __ ] a bull you see the size of that
[ __ ] bull i mean if you guys ever
seen a whale penis look how shacked that
bull is
dude those women must be [ __ ] lusting
yeah they gotta be this which is
projection big time of course
they're like they're like you think
they're already [ __ ] right they are
yeah they're [ __ ] lusting off that
[ __ ]
like damn it
so
when
zeus shows up he's dressed like that he
is yeah
women are falling for it how are you
going to compete with that that's what
they're thinking so they were kind of
like
well back in the old days
those were kind of like in cells because
they're like well the reason we're not
getting laid is because zeus is going
around being a sexy bull
and he's getting all the ladies there
you go or a sexy shower yeah you
understand or whatever well the shower
that's the [ __ ] that's the ancient
equivalent of a shower of [ __ ]
thousand dollar bills
which it would be awesome
i don't want to [ __ ] it but if somebody
wants to shower me with thousand dollar
bills
ancient man what mattered was when he's
dirty how jacked the dude was how big
his dick was and how much money he had
so they had all that covered
god shows up as a shower of money to hit
these women
how are you going to compete with that
and can't compete with this he's made of
money yeah he's literally money those
women are rolling in this [ __ ] nowadays
it would be like [ __ ] cryptocurrency
or
[ __ ] god shows up and her [ __ ] atm
[ __ ] just goes
but she i [ __ ]
every time she [ __ ] looks at her
[ __ ] debit card there's more money
there how is she gonna res how are you
gonna compete with that
can't compete with it so it's
supernatural cucking
is what it is
stories of supernatural cucking
god is so badass that he's cucking you
out
you will never compete with him well
that's why he's a god and you're not a
god you're not a guy
well then you have like an excuse for
being lame though because she's like
well i can't compete with that so you
know exactly women are the worst and i'm
just going to like my power be my
daughter myself yeah power big dick and
[ __ ] [ __ ] it we've already lost i
just yeah
so we're just gonna give up yep we're
gonna give up and [ __ ] the sheep
well
i mean you know hypothetically it sounds
like it sounds it sounds like they're
rationalizing why they're not getting
laid
well yeah that's exactly what it is
they're rationalized greenspark says
supernatural cuck should be a bad name
[Laughter]
cucking your ass out
slasher fred says there is an urban
legend about a family on vacation and
the grandmother dies and they put her
body in the roof of their car and it was
used in the 1983 classic vacation yes
that's true and actually uh i think that
uh he talks about that in this book
actually and there's also
there's another i can't remember because
i haven't seen a vacation in a long time
but there's a further like the story
goes further than that it's like grandma
dies on the vacation they put they tie
her body up because they're out in the
middle of nowhere or whatever they put
her on the roof of the car because
they're gonna take her someplace and the
car gets stolen so it's kind of like a
funny
i mean morbidly funny that's kind of
[ __ ] i think it's funny but you know the
so i don't know if they did that in the
movie or not but that's like part of the
urban legend as well that the car
eventually gets stolen with the body on
top of it okay tammy says she googled it
she
she says just google it he disappeared
in 2008
found in 2015 less than a mile from a
home in a chimney of an abandoned cabin
okay so he was trying to go into a
mannequin trying to get him a cabin yeah
for i don't know why i thought he was
trying to get back in his own house no
he's a cat i might think that's right
he's been up there for a long time
yeah i thought it was a while i thought
it was a long time
his family was looking for him yeah he
wasn't a criminal or anything he was
just trying to get that damn cabin
you know probably to unlock it so he
could have access to it yeah evidently
nobody was using it
bring your girls in there man bring some
girls [ __ ] you have a date you have
your own cabin nobody's been in there
for a long time
i can if you don't have any money your
young guy can understand that yeah i'm
going to use this cabin
yeah
victor says supernatural cooking is
abandoned austin
is it is it already a band look that
[ __ ] up okay
i find that hard to believe that we're
just like talking about that you just
like said some random [ __ ] and there was
a band called that but everything i say
is about i don't know i believe it yeah
yeah you can make band names out of all
the kind of stuff yeah but yeah so uh
okay so vanishing hitchhiker story like
i said very very old
maybe goes back to bible times in
certain variations but the first time
that folklorists actually studied it and
this is like i said this is what i find
really interesting in the early 1940s so
you had two folklorists richard
beardsley and rosalie henke
and they decided they were going to try
and figure out where the story came from
so they started collecting
uh all these different accounts of it
like they started asking people to tell
them their versions of it
so they ended up getting uh 79
different written accounts of this same
story from all over the u.s
now what they found they categorized
them into four different versions
now the
what they called they called them a b c
and d
uh the a version the most common one and
this is the one that i heard
uh the ones where the hitchhiker uh you
know they they pick somebody up the
hitchhiker gives the address
and then later on like the motorist
stops in front of the house turns around
the girls disappeared he goes up to the
house and finds out that the girl is
dead and usually like died right on the
road where he picked her up that's the
most common one 49 of the uh accounts
they got were that variation of the
story
uh
across 16 states that came from
uh the b story
uh was versions where
the hitchhiker was actually an old woman
and she usually had some kind of
prophecy about some disaster that was
going to happen and these were usually
from the 1940s because they usually had
to do
with
either world war ii was gonna end or
there was something bad was gonna happen
having to do with like the uh century of
progress exposition around which took
place in chicago around this time so
they think that this is like a local
variation uh that
came about like in the chicago area
because a lot of them were based around
that particular thing and this old lady
was just like oh this bad thing is going
to happen it's like the whole place is
going to flood or some [ __ ] like that um
so that was another variation
there were also other variations where
the girl
uh is actually not
doesn't get picked up on the road but
she's at like a dance or someplace like
that and then she leaves a coat or
something
on the grave that's like the third
variation and then there's another one
where
the uh again where the hitchhiker is
usually
figured out to be like some kind of
saint or deity or something like that so
that's another version and there were
also versions this is very strange i had
actually never heard this version but
there's a another variation where
it's actually not the hitchhiker who
turns out to be a ghost but somebody
stops and picks up the hitchhiker and it
turns out that the driver of the car is
a ghost
there's also another variation where
it's actually two people on a train
who start talking to one and it's
usually a man and a woman and they start
talking to each other and one of them's
reading a book about ghosts but then
says oh i don't really believe in them
and then like the other passenger like
vanishes so they were a ghost the whole
time so that's like kind of another
variation of this but this is like a
very very old very very common uh legend
so uh another one that i wanted to talk
about that probably a lot of people have
heard and actually i think they even
put this one because this one a
variation of this was in uh scary
stories to tell in the dark like the
book series and then i think they put it
in the movie that we saw the guillermo
del toro one
uh so it's called the spider bite or the
red spot very very common uh kind of
squeaky urban legend and this uh
started out in the 1970s sometime came
from england uh and then kind of went
across the united states
so usually the protagonist is almost
always a young woman like a teenager or
someone in her 20s
and she's usually from somewhere
uh that's colder uh you know whether
it's england whether it's you know
somewhere in new england or new york
city somewhere like that
uh story usually goes that she goes on
vacation somewhere
warm and in the south usually somewhere
like mexico southern california
something like that
uh she's usually sunbathing on the beach
by the side of a pool something like
that and is bitten on the cheek by a
spider
uh at this point the bite like swells up
into this big boil and she goes home to
get medical treatment and uh the doctor
lances the boil and then like a whole
bunch of like baby spiders
crawl out of it yeah so this is a very
common and there are other variations of
this too
it's not no uh but it's a very very
common urban legend and there's a little
bit of weird
again we're talking about
anxieties because a lot of people don't
like spiders okay i get that um i don't
mind spiders so it doesn't gross me out
all that much i don't want them crawling
around the face but you know um but it
doesn't like bother me as much as it
might bother other people but
again there's kind of that thing about
because almost always the girl it's
almost always a girl because you know
vanity and you have to be beautiful and
blah blah and there's like a usually a
whole thing about oh my god i have this
big zit now it's a big boil and you know
it's so it's a whole like i'm not pretty
anymore thing so
almost always the the girl at the center
is from
up north somewhere yeah and she's
vacationing down south somewhere
somewhere hot or somewhere foreign
and
it's uh it's so it's like a foreign
invasion
type uh
meme there's like there's a whole subset
of urban legends that are like that
there's one called the mexican pet
which uh actually jan brenban wrote a
book called that
and the story goes that this like uber
white uh couple goes down to mexico on
vacation
and they buy a pet that they think is a
chihuahua and then they get it home and
it gets sick and they take it to a vet
and they're like yo that's a rat
right
i know but like i said that's a pretty
common but like i said so there's a lot
of this kind of like distrust of the
foreign yeah uh you know going on in
these urban legends which is very very
funny there's like that's a that's a
strain that goes through there all right
so what tammy messaged me he says the
article goes on to say that he was only
wearing a shirt no pants or shoes talk
about the guy that tried to get down in
the damn chimney interesting no i i
don't know where the pants and the shoes
were i don't know if they were found on
the roof or if they were found
but he was probably trying to take all
that stuff off while he was stuck in
that chimney to get smaller
to keep continue going down maybe that's
going to go up
but yeah i don't know the details
wouldn't surprise me if he tried to
take his pants off to get down there
because maybe he was stuck in there and
somehow was able to
trying to get out like thinking that he
would be like that he'd be able to go
down if he took his pants off he'd be
able to slide down even further but
you'd think they'd probably find the
pants at the bottom of the damn yeah
that's never mentioned is it unless they
found the pants a long time ago and took
them away
didn't know that there was not like a
random pants random pants random shirt
although you would think i would think
that if you found pants and shoes at the
bottom of chimney you'd think you'd look
up and be like hey who did that belong
to well maybe the person that found the
pants in the shoes was dead long dead
didn't think much of it like who's
trying to burn this up and then threw it
away and that person died or never told
anybody about it and and then died later
it's probably what it was trying to get
skinnier to go down the [ __ ] shaft
bad way to die
you'd be that's what i'm saying that
would suck a lot he'd be there at least
seven days till he died dehydration
yeah
yeah
begging to get out of there
dark just looking at the damn [ __ ]
light coming in through the top yeah no
thanks
so again nobody say that don't be
sliding don't [ __ ] go down and find
me
yeah please don't
that's like nobody wants to go like that
stupid it's a darwin award you know
natural selection
me and jenny came from a whole
generation of natural selections they'd
let our asses out [ __ ] during the day
when we were little kids and don't come
back till dark
[ __ ] when the street lights come on
that's right
for dinner
you [ __ ] uh the kids that didn't end
up on [ __ ] america's most wanted or
whatever or on the back of the milk
carton yeah on the back of the middle
carton they survived it was just as
nature intended
that's [ __ ] up
[ __ ] go out and [ __ ] have fun
don't come back until the [ __ ] street
lights come on
and
sadly um
a lot because i know like a lot of
people that grew up like that like
particularly in the 50s and everything
like that you could just ride your bikes
all day and it was fine uh it wasn't
fine there was a lot of serial killers
and kidnappers and pedophiles running
around back then too it's just they
didn't really like talk about it as much
it was rare
so it wasn't in there although not as
rare as you might think isn't it it's
not that great man [ __ ] we'd be out
[ __ ] in california [ __ ] i was a
little kid [ __ ] run around [ __ ]
dudes to stop the car asking us for
direction be like
we'd run from them yeah we we knew
better if you had instincts [ __ ] you
know
yeah you know you you don't talk to
strangers
parents told you well the scary thing
though was that the scary thing though
is that sometimes it wasn't a stranger
like if it was a small town like it was
somebody you kind of knew but then they
turned out to be like a [ __ ] no
usually the person that did get you for
somebody you knew that's what i'm saying
yeah
victor said i literally almost got
kidnapped as a kid yeah i think that a
lot of kids grew up in that era did have
like some weird like you know close
calls sure because it was [ __ ]
weirdos back then too it's not i
remember it wasn't some idyllic
you know golden age or something like
that there was [ __ ] perverts running
around back then too we had defenses
though
we had defenses we were always [ __ ]
got each other's back to be a bunch of
us the whole [ __ ] there'd be a gang
of little boys running around [ __ ]
carson california with a gang with a
pack of damn dogs
the little boys and the dogs would all
be together
you didn't you weren't there for that
if you was more than i wasn't you
weren't there for that yeah i was what
are you talking about there'd be like
three or four boys you grew up i had
brothers i had [ __ ] time and then
about seven or eight [ __ ] dogs
following you around wherever you went
and then we go down the wildlife
preserve and [ __ ]
and the dogs that [ __ ] attack people
if the [ __ ] would protect you too
if if we'd start fighting with each
other the dogs would [ __ ] choose
sides
[Laughter]
oh which kid they were going to support
in the fight
but this is the way it was
you know
but no we uh
it was natural selection
yeah but that's victim blaming that's
not victor yes it is it's just if you
made the wrong decisions you died
it is victim blaming uh the way it goes
that's
[ __ ] the world you should probably
like stop talking the world you should
probably stop you should probably stop
talking
uh tammy says uh
the rest of his clothes were folded
laying inside the cabin he was also
upside down in the fetal position
article goes on to say it might have
been murder
wait a minute hold on read that back
again what'd they say the rest of his
clothes were folded laying inside the
cabin he was also upside down in the
fetal position article goes on to say it
might have been murder
upside down the field in the chimney
yeah
so maybe somebody like dropped him down
there
i don't know maybe he went down head
first i don't know i mean why would you
do that though i kind of feel like if
you're going down that well that's what
i'm saying a normal person would not go
down head first because that's stupid so
maybe somebody else
put him in there i mean the weirder
things have happened you know
weird things have happened but also
dudes have done stupid [ __ ] tried to go
down something like that hit first well
yeah i'm not saying that i'm just saying
that they found one kid
okay they found one kid in a gymnasium
he was missing for [ __ ] days
and then you know those exercise mats
that they had
yeah remember those things well they had
rolled them up into tubes and had them
standing up in a corner
and kid was missing for [ __ ] days
they found his ass [ __ ] head first
going down into one of those tubes oh
yeah he fell down in that tube somehow
and couldn't turn around and get back up
and they couldn't hear his cries for
help
and he was upside down in there and
[ __ ] died
now
[ __ ] thing about it was is that the
reason why it was remembered it was
always controversy it was a it was
pretty much an all-white school
and that kid happened to be a black kid
and they were kind of accused and people
maybe somebody threw them down there
but no it's not what it was but he was
popular he was playing around like any
other kid
and uh
decided to [ __ ] darren jim class
decided to go down one of those [ __ ]
in one of those rolled up mats [ __ ]
for some reason head first in case
because he thought he could come back
out
but no you couldn't nimbus high school
terrible but it said it wouldn't it
would kill you pretty quick because
you're upside down it has something to
do with flicking the way the blood flow
goes i mean that still wouldn't be fun
though no terrible it's but they said he
probably was dead within about 10 hours
that's a long 10 hours
well at least it wasn't seven days
well yeah but okay i'm sure i'm sure
being in that situation wasn't yeah he
wasn't thinking that way nope
he couldn't he couldn't [ __ ]
get the strength together to [ __ ]
crawl backwards up out of that damn
rolled up mat
and we'll think about it you weigh a
certain amount of pounds you know what i
mean how much strength would it take
how constricted would you would you be
and you're a [ __ ]
teenager you wouldn't think that [ __ ]
just doing something as dumb as
jumping down there for fun
you wouldn't think that you couldn't get
back out until it was too late well
that's what you get for thinking that's
what happened as my dad used to say yeah
yeah
john gore says tom savini was picked up
and abused as a child by some rando so
he says
uh yeah i've heard i've heard of that
like i said i think it's a lot more
widespread than people thought uh back
then it's just that people didn't really
talk about it depends on the area so
probably well yeah but i mean i've
written enough about enough true crime
cases to know that [ __ ] absolutely did
go on a lot back then california
that was a lot of it
i mean everywhere honestly
a lot of [ __ ] went on in the midwest too
yeah i mean a lot of weird [ __ ] went on
in the middle well i think it was two
different factors california you had
population density uh so statistically
something's going to happen there
and then we talk about midwest and
certain places in the south you have a
low population density so all it takes
is just one maniac to be out there
chances are he'll evade detection
because there's there's no witnesses
so
two separate effects happening
which we've talked about that before
yeah
uh all right so where was i so i was
talking about the uh spider bite legend
and i was gonna say that there's
actually another variation of that which
came out like probably about the 1960s
when
girls started wearing like uh bouffants
and like their hair all ratted you know
what i mean like
up in those big hairdos and so there was
another urban legend that was similar
that uh the hairdos like you never you
ratted it up and you never washed it so
then it got full of spiders and then
they would like all kind of like run out
so that was another common thing now all
of these kind of
invasion by
creepy crawlies stories
folklorists usually call these
quote unquote bosom serpent stories
now this is from a nathaniel hawthorne
story from 1843 called egotism or the
bosom serpent
and that's pretty much any
urban legend that has to do with any
kind of like
usually gross animal spite like insects
like you know the thing about earwigs
like crawling through your head and [ __ ]
like that because there was that was a
big thing in the late 80s too hold on
one second camp guy a couple of people
are chiming in about the guy in the
rolled-up mat
they think that he accidentally dropped
his shoe down in there because his shoe
was there so he tried to go down and did
that's a quick good explanation that
sounds about right
he went down there to get his shoe
dj maniac says the spider bite one
exists in modern times except they
update it to people with dreadlocks you
can imagine all the [ __ ] i've heard for
30 years yeah anytime anybody has
a hairstyle
that
looks like they don't wash it
you know what i mean uh they're gonna
have this thing oh they got bugs in
their hair and that's like i said that's
been going on
forever like since
well the 60s like with the bouffants
because that was like the big you know
with the [ __ ] ratting and stuff to
make it really big
and
and people perceived that it wasn't
clean or you didn't wash it so that was
another thing there it was almost kind
of like a low-key way to call people
dirty you know what i mean because they
were like all full of uh spiders but
like i said the bosom serpent story
folklorists call it that again based on
the nathaniel hawthorne story and there
are other variations of this where
there's uh there's another legend
usually it has to do with like a mom and
a baby like usually the baby will be
like in a you know a carrier or some
kind the mom goes to like pick
strawberries like in a strawberry field
and leaves the baby like sleeping in the
carrier like at the end of the row
and
because the baby has milk on its lips or
something like that for whatever reason
a snake
is attracted to the milk on the lips
which doesn't happen because snakes
don't eat don't drink milk but whatever
um you know what i mean it's it's an
urban legend like i said it doesn't have
to make sense
it only kind of makes sense if you're
episodes like oh that's a good story but
if you think about it for two seconds
they're like wait what that snake didn't
give a [ __ ] about milk no what is yeah
snake's already built so um but yeah but
so he's attracted by the milk on the
baby's lips and either crawls down the
baby's throat and suffocates it or
strangles the baby like trying to get
the milk so that's like another very
common uh legend which he also talked
about in this book as well those [ __ ]
milk snakes i know milk snakes
incidentally the reason that this is
called i mean if you couldn't tell from
the illustration uh the reason it's
called curse is broiled again thank you
zack did you hear the one about the
couple who stays in the hotel room for
their anniversary and watches porn but
it's of them on their wedding night i
have heard that one didn't they make
that into a hor well i don't know if it
was exactly that but what there was a
horror movie called
was it called no vacancy i want to say
and it was a couple and they stopped at
this like shifty motel
i haven't seen in a long time so forgive
me and then they found like all these
videotapes in there that were
like porn or like snuff-porn of people
that had stayed in that exact room
so i kind of feel like that's a pretty
common
i mean that's a pretty common there's i
think he talked about that in here too
because this book is like the first
section is like horrors
and then it's all like about automotive
stuff which some of those are pretty
horrific too because honestly
the urban legends that last the longest
are frankly like the most gruesome ones
like one of the automotive ones that he
talks about in this is
uh one story that was going on in the
late 80s it might still be like pretty
common nowadays but it usually has to do
with
uh two
semi-trucks and they get in some kind of
like uh head-on collision uh usually
it's kind of like they're on mountain
roads one of them's going up a mountain
and one of them's coming down the
mountain like they hit each other
head-on
and the you know both drivers are killed
and the wreckage is so intertwined with
one another that the tow truck or
whatever
takes the wreckage away like without
pulling it apart and then later like at
the you know dump or whatever like
everybody's like when man what's that
smell like coming out of that [ __ ] and
they pry the
uh semis apart and they find usually
like a vw beetle like smooshed in
between the two trucks and like four or
five people dead in there like just like
smashed all the hell um again talking
about anxieties about driving especially
these like little compact cars and stuff
uh there have been like some really
grotesque
car accidents i'm not saying that but
as far as i could determine there's
never been an accident exactly like that
where
because honestly if two semi-trucks hit
each other head-on which has happened
um
they wouldn't just leave them fused
together like that i mean especially if
they thought that maybe there was other
bodies or they would they just wouldn't
do that so it
it just wouldn't happen that they're you
know
that you would leave like a whole car
in the [ __ ]
no need for me too says wow still going
awesome [ __ ] i haven't even like got to
most of my stuff i mean like i said we
we don't have to cover everything that i
talked about in here but we've got a lot
of stuff but yeah so i i mean i just
wanted like a good like combo of like
[ __ ] to like talk about
um but yeah so
so that yeah so this book has got like
all kind of different stuff and he's got
stuff like
uh one that i just saw a movie the other
day there's there's an urban legend
about somebody it's usually like a dude
like a working class guy
and he works on some kind of
construction site or something or in a
factory or whatever and he somehow gets
like caught in a piece of machinery
but not killed outright
but it's always kind of like some sort
of situation where well they can't get
him out of the machine without killing
him but they can't turn on the machine
again without killing him
so they have to like call his wife and
his wife has to come and like kiss him
goodbye because they're gonna turn the
machine on and he's gonna die
so that's another very common one and
that's kind of like all over the world
because he um collected ones from like
new zealand and [ __ ] like that there all
that was different was like the machine
involved but see i can't see
how that would happen though i don't i
can't see how i'm like i can see how
somebody could get stuck in machinery
obviously and killed because that
happens all the time
but i can't see how
you would get stuck in machinery whereas
you can't leave it off or turn it on
and the person be i don't know i mean i
get a machine apart that's what i'm
saying so i kind of feel like i get why
these stories are popular but as i said
if you think about them for five minutes
it's like you know that that's probably
not true but you know
um
here's another story this is this is
actually one of my favorite urban
legends and i've seen like a lot of
variations of this let's see if you've
heard this you probably have i feel like
a lot of people have read this one
uh so this one is called the licked hand
have you heard that one do you know what
i'm talking about
no
um
now there were versions of this going
around i i don't know
it's been around for a while now the
earliest one in print that they could
find was from 1982 as far as i know but
i think it was going around before that
because that's the thing with urban
legends a lot of times they were like
oral folklore before somebody like
like wrote them down like wrote a short
story or something like he's watching
you on this screen
are you really yeah i'm seeing you move
over there she's like what there's a
little bitty mommy over there
she's wigging out
[Laughter]
so story goes the most common version
this is the version that i heard
so there's a young woman it's usually
like a college student or something like
that she usually lives alone
uh and she has a dog
and she's listening to the news and
hears over the news that there's you
know the obviously killer on the loose
like i said sounds like a horror movie
so she locks all the doors in the
windows in the house but uh she in most
versions of the story she forgets one
window it's usually like a basement
window or some window you don't think
about our bathroom window or something
like that
so she goes to bed uh her dog comes with
her and her dog like goes under the bed
and goes to sleep
she wakes up in the middle of the night
and she hears a dripping sound coming
from the bathroom which is what like
freaks her out
uh she's so freaked out that she's kind
of too scared to get up and find out
what that noise is
but it makes her feel better like she
puts her hand down under the bed and she
feels the dog which she thinks is the
dog lick her hand and she's like okay
well the dog's there everything's okay
the dog's not freaking out so
everything's fine
so she goes uh back to sleep
next morning she wakes up goes into the
bathroom
and finds her dead mutilated dog hanging
in the shower with blood dripping down
onto the tiles which is what the
dripping noise was
on the shower wall written in the dog's
blood are the words humans can lick too
i love that story i don't know why
obviously it didn't happen definitely
[ __ ] that's a great [ __ ] story
though now there are like some different
versions that story always used to like
freak me out i'm like oh that's such a
good story uh i've seen this in movies
too now there are other variations it's
not always a young girl it usually is
sometimes it's kind of like a half-blind
older woman
um you know the breed of the dog
varies sometimes it's the [ __ ] that
happens to the dog is like way more
graphic like sometimes it's skinned or
disemboweled or something like that a
message is sometimes on the floor the
bathroom mirror rather than on the wall
and there's also other versions uh where
the parents come home and actually find
the killer hiding in the house uh
usually in the basement or the closet or
something like that
um
you know so there's you know different
versions of this uh the
pretty much the dog always dies
unfortunately uh sometimes the girl dies
as well
uh sometimes the killer's in the house
sometimes not
honestly though uh this might be a an
updating of a very old story
from 1919 there was a story by mr james
the very famous english ghost story
writer and it was called the diary of mr
poynter i kind of feel like i've read
that one i don't remember if i read it
on my witching hour series but i know
i've read it
and there is a scene in that where
there's a dude and he's like at a desk
or something like that and he's reading
a manuscript
about uh
a student dying and he's like petting
what he thinks is his dog like next to
the desk and then he looks down and he
sees that it's not a dog like it's a
person
and it's like a killer so i think that
might be where this came from but
honestly i always really liked that
story that's for some reason i really uh
dig that when humans can lick too i'm
just really into that um so
somebody mentioned this one earlier and
i wanted to talk about this one too
killer in the back seat
uh this is a very this is another one
that i actually really like uh this
story is also known as high beams
uh and you'll know why in a second uh
this is very common in the us and also
in the uk
this was first um collected by
folklorists in 1968
and they got the stories from uh
students at indiana university it might
have been circulating prior to that but
that's the first time that it was
collected by folklorists so that's like
the earliest written record of it
so story goes that there's a woman and
she's uh on her own and she's driving
and there's a car truck that's following
her
and this person that's following her uh
keeps flashing their high beams and
they're like driving really close to the
car sometimes even like bumping her on
the bumper and [ __ ] like that and she's
like freaking out thinking oh my god
this is serial killer which is what you
would think because like what the [ __ ]
so uh so she does that
but uh usually the twist in the story is
that
what is actually going on
is that there is a murderer in the back
seat of her car
and the person that is behind her is
trying to warn her about it and the
reason that they keep flashing their
high beams is that every time the killer
kind of pops up to like kill her
he turns his high beams on to like scare
the dude it'll like duck him back down
um and that's the reason like he's
trying to be like hey lady you know
there's a killer in your back seat like
you might want to take care of that
situation
um so that's uh another and there's
another version too
where
uh a woman gets into her car and then a
crazy person jumps out and starts
like yelling and slamming their hands on
the car and then she's like what the
[ __ ] and she drives away but then every
time she
like wherever she drives however she
fast she drives this dude keeps like
popping up and like hitting her car and
yelling and she can't figure out what
the [ __ ] going on and then she stops
at a police station and says what the
hell there's this dude that keeps
popping out of like hitting my car
and then
the cops like drive her back to her
house
but then when they go with her back to
the car they find
again the killer in the back seat and it
turned out that the person that was
outside of her car hitting the car was
actually like a ghost of like this
killer's former victim who's trying to
like warner about it so
the the this story has to do usually
with
a woman driving thinking that the threat
is coming from outside when it's
actually coming from inside so it's
almost kind of like a vehicular
variation of like the
babysitter in the man upstairs story you
know what i mean where the call is
coming from inside the house the killer
is coming from inside the car pretty
much and it's usually a kind of thing
where
the woman is feels threatened by the
person behind them who is usually like a
bit like a scary looking dude so it's
somebody that if you are a woman driving
alone you would think oh my god this is
absolutely a serial killer but then it's
always kind of like an inversion where
this person is actually trying to save
you from the actual killer who is
already in your car
so it's kind of like it's almost kind of
like a moral which a lot of urban
legends are where it has a moral like
don't judge a book by its cover type of
thing because it's usually
because i've seen variations too where
a woman will pull up at like a gas
station this is probably like the
version that i heard earliest she'll
pull up at like a gap like a remote gas
station and then like the
the dude that's like running the gas
station's like sketchy as [ __ ] right and
he's like really weird and she thinks
that he's the one that's endangered but
he's like trying to warn her about this
dude that's in the back and she doesn't
realize it so she's just kind of like
like that guy's killer so it's always it
always has that kind of like inversion
thing where the threat that you think is
like you know happening is not the
person that's actually the threat um
again so
i kind of feel like yeah this has been
going around since the 1960s
um
probably got popular in the early 80s
mostly because i think it turned up a
variation of it turned up in the uh anne
landers column in the uh newspaper
now interestingly there might have been
a real story that inspired this
uh there was a case in 1964
in which a guy uh who was a murderer
he'd escaped from jail and he did
actually hide in the back seat of
somebody's car
however the owner of the car in this
case was not uh a young woman on her own
but was actually a police detective and
ended up shooting the dude
[Laughter]
so that actually for him so yeah so he
really did pick the wrong car but that's
uh that might have been where where the
story originally came from so it did
actually come from like a real uh story
sort of how long has been online
three or three hours okay why
just keeping track of the [ __ ] time
because we you have a lot of material
left
you said you didn't have to do it all
we'll just see if they i'm just skipping
around okay like just talking about
stories that i like okay you know what i
mean right there's a couple that i
definitely do want to um
get to because i like them and i don't
think they're as common because you said
you wanted something to eat
well eventually yeah so we may want to
end this within about an hour yeah
that's fine okay i mean four hours is
fine okay slasher fred says there is an
urban tale where teen girl discovers her
deceased lover hanging upside down by
his feet yeah that's usually um
i kind of that's uh that's not usually
the hook story though because the hook
story
they usually both get away right i mean
that's like a that's like a close call
type of story where they find the hook
on the handle the story where
the guy where they hear something
outside the car they're making out and
they hear something outside the car
and then the dude doesn't come back
but then the girl is like sitting in the
car and she keeps hearing a dripping
sound yeah yeah that's like a separate
story it's related but that's like a
different story and then she's like she
gets out and the dude's like skinned and
he's hanging upside down yeah i've heard
that one too
it's for some reason i associate that
with the hook story but i guess that's
kind of like a teenagers making out in
their car urban legend there's like a
whole subset of those um so another one
i want to talk about is the choking
doberman have you heard that one
the choking doberman now this is a uh
urban legend originating in the us
now uh what happens with this one this
was actually uh yanburn van wrote a book
called the choking doberman and other
new urban legends that was back in 1984.
and this was a pretty uh comment i think
it's older than this but this for
whatever reason this was kind of a hot
legend around the uh early to mid 80s
and uh basically what happened so
there's a lady and she lives by herself
again
and she goes out one night with her
friends
she comes home and she has a dog it's
usually a doberman although in more
recent uh iterations of the tail it's
usually a pit bull or a rottweiler
but in the 80s it was almost always a
doberman
she comes home and the doberman is
choking so she gets freaked out and
takes the pet to like an emergency
veterinarian
the vet says he has to do a tracheotomy
and uh it's like you know i'll call you
back and come back when uh you know when
i can tell you what's going on
so the woman gets home and then the vet
calls her
and says get out of the house right now
because what the dog was choking on
was three human fingers
and maybe
the dude whose fingers that are it was
are is still in your house
so uh the woman ends up calling the cops
they search the house and they find the
fingerless
uh dude hiding in a closet who is passed
out from blood loss
uh
why do you have to say that every time
it's an urban legend by its very nature
it is not true all right so you don't
have to say you don't buy it nobody buys
it it's an urban legend
um that's kind of it goes with the
territory
now interestingly there might be as i
said there's more recent versions of
this where the dog breed has changed
sometimes has a little bit of a racist
spin on it where it'll say it was a
black man's fingers or a mexican man's
face like they're mexican fingers yeah
yeah like i think that's like certain
yes
you can pick them out of a [ __ ] line
it's like
but like i said that all of these kind
of little details that get added it just
says something about the person telling
the story that is like very funny but
yeah so originally it was just and
obviously the number of fingers changes
sometimes it's three sometimes four
sometimes it's five whatever um
but there is actually a really old
version of this sort of
from
if you would believe it from 1800 bc
and this was kind of a story there was a
dude about a dude named llewellyn the
great which is very welsh so i'm
assuming this is like a welsh story
and he had a dog named gellert i guess
and in this legend uh llewellyn leaves
his young son at home with the dog and
he goes out hunting
llewellyn comes back
and the dog runs up to him and has blood
all over his face and like a dumbass
llewellyn first jumps to oh my god he
has blood on his face that must mean he
killed my son
so he kills the dog
and then he goes
and finds actually his kid is alive but
there's a dead wolf so the dog had
actually killed the wolf like protecting
the boy and this [ __ ] like killed the
dog because he just like jumped to
[ __ ] conclusions so that's like kind
of similar they think that maybe that's
where the germ of this story came from
but again very very common
uh i think the first written appearance
of it was
uh 1981
and it was kind of printed as
maybe something that happened but i mean
they printed in the paper but they were
like well we heard this story but we
couldn't verify any of the details of it
so
to make of that what you will so that's
what they printed but it did kind of
seem to be going around a lot in the 80s
i don't think i said because i started
to say something that i think you
interrupted me or something and or
i got no no that never never interrupted
you yeah never um but uh
this book why it's called that um
is because one of the hot legends that
was going around in the late 1980s
was uh the story that a woman who was
it's usually like a bridesmaid
and she decided she wanted to be like
super tan because it was the 80s you
guys and that was like all the rage you
had to be like super tan
and
she uh went to like a whole bunch of
different tanning salons because
apparently tanning salons in the legend
had like limits on how long you could be
in the tanning bed so you didn't know
that's true which yeah but like i said
according to the legend so she had to
like circumvent that by going to a bunch
of different ones and then
she started i think usually most of most
of the time the legend started with she
she goes to all these ones and then
she's kind of like she started smelling
really bad
and like her mom complains to her about
it and she ends up going to the doctor
and the doctor ends up telling her very
uh very seriously well you have gone to
all of these tanning beds and you have
cooked your insides yeah right
which like i said
it's not good to like lay in tanning
beds all the time because ultraviolet
you you know you will get skin cancer
but i think they're confusing
ultraviolet rays with microwaves
um those are two different things right
um you know it like i said it's not good
to like lay in a tanning bed for too
long obviously but you're not gonna cook
your insides like like it's a microwave
it's not a microwave but they're kind of
like acting like it's a microwave if you
cooked your insides you would feel the
heat you would be able to stand it
so it's like how funny is that though
it's like you're you're you're you're
gonna be [ __ ] second-degree burning
oh bridesmaid in a wedding and it's just
like yeah i'm gonna be in all these
[ __ ]
tanning beds and then your mom's like
why do you smell like boiled pork
[Laughter]
wow i smell delicious because you're
cooking your inside i remember the
tanning craze that was the [ __ ]
california look yeah
yeah i kind of feel like that's why i
think that's why that urban legend is
not really around all that much anymore
because people don't really do you're
right the tanning bed thing in the 80s
it was very big um they made a lot of
money they did yeah because everybody
wanted to be super ev everybody wanted
to look like malibu barbie pretty much
like you had to be super tan and like
super cool you just buy a couple of them
damn tanning beds and you could [ __ ]
rent a [ __ ] retail space in one of
those strip malls
and uh yeah you can make you can make a
living on that just having these chicks
if i could sit in that damn [ __ ] bed
on a timer
like it was a service
i guess it was a service i mean in
certain parts of the world i mean it
seems like a waste in like florida and
california when you can literally just
like lay outside for free
uh and get the same thing it's okay to
get a get some color with you know your
caucasian get some color good it's good
for you but over overdoing it is bad for
you i mean you need a little bit you
need some vitamin d but some of the [ __ ]
they were doing was [ __ ] they were
just like tanning themselves [ __ ]
bronze constantly
not if you're white that's not good for
your skin you don't have the melanin
continent yeah you're just you're just
getting a person
they're born with [ __ ] protection for
that i mean my pale ass i'm just gonna
get skin cancer we are glacier gliders
we weren't meant for that yeah [ __ ]
right i was not honestly i never even i
i don't think i ever even tanned i just
went from like pale as [ __ ] to burned
yeah yeah i did with nothing with
nothing in between
i can tan it just doesn't last long
yeah i just weeks and it's gone because
my mom used to take me to the beach when
i was a kid because my mom loved the
beach i didn't love it but you know we
would go and honestly
i tried to stay out of the sun but even
like after a brief time i would just get
super red and just peel yeah well if you
get too much you peel
i may be and my brother one time
actually got heat stroke like his face
swelled up
that's how bad like he got like [ __ ]
sunburned you have to get a slight tan
first
to start building up
some defenses well yeah you have to like
layer it you can't just like lay out for
hours because you'll just cook it'll
just burn
yeah if you're white like i said like i
said a black person wouldn't even notice
that
they wouldn't even notice it you could
put them in those tanning beds and they
would go what's this all about
jeffy yard says in multiple tanning beds
you're more likely to pick up an std
yeah probably there's probably all kind
of [ __ ] cooties in those things
how i mean how i don't know about that
do they really wash those i mean yeah
they probably [ __ ] spread them down
if i can wipe them i hope so yeah
although i guess it's maybe not
not any dirtier than a gym yeah well a
lot of those a lot of those girls that
were doing that um were in
bikinis because they wanted tan lines
tan lines was like uh like part of the
sexiness of it and i remember that look
it did look good it was like it's kind
of like a
girls wearing lingerie we should have
anything on you can see lines
i remember it
well yeah i do too i'm the same age as
you he always he always says i remember
it like no one else does
like i know i remember i was just trying
to read into what i said i just i just
remember it i remembered it it was good
it was just a different time i didn't
like it i thought it looked trashy but
you know depended on the girl depending
on the girl against us because they
always had like this bottle blonde and
they always had like these really dark
roots it just looked real trashy all
right well you got grafters in here man
we were in michigan during a lot of that
time and you had some girls that were up
north that had nothing to do with the
beach they shouldn't have been tanned
for [ __ ] but they did have [ __ ]
bleach blonde hair and fake [ __ ]
tants it was kind of orange looking tan
yeah because then put it on that i mean
the tanning [ __ ] they had back in the
old days that lotion was like
where we lived in the michigan area it
was scandinavian women these are like
[ __ ] polish
girls of polish descent [ __ ]
uh uh somewhere more like swedish and
they don't tan too well you know it
would take a long time to get a decent
tan on them but they were tanned
artificially they kind of looked orange
and the hairstyles of that day looked
like some they would look like something
damn poodle would wear you know
curly hair well they were bit and their
hair was like real thin because they
bleached it and it would get like crispy
and then they would like kind of ride
and then they would kind of like crimp
it and put like a bunch of hairspray
yeah
and like kind of stick it up so it
looked really thin and wispy yeah and
crunchy and then
too much [ __ ] bon jovi and they were
wearing [ __ ] fringe leather jackets
and fringe on their boots and [ __ ] they
didn't have trying to look like some
kind of biker girl they didn't have
motorcycles although that was a special
type of check we call them taylor
billy's that's what they look like they
kind of had that
but you know the girls we were hanging
out with and trenton didn't look like
that a lot of them were like kind of
like punk rockers and new wave type
girls that's what they you know they
chick like chicks like maryland and uh
remember the other ones [ __ ]
i can oh [ __ ]
i'm trying to remember
[ __ ] gene petrowski i'm still in
touch with jean jean doesn't look
anything like she used to this little
punk rock girl that it was the first
girl i ever [ __ ] messed with she had
a tattoo and that [ __ ] was a big deal
back in the 80s
yeah girls didn't have tattoos in the
80s unless they were like biker mamas i
got pictures of gene i'm gonna pull
picture in jean from back in the 80s
she had a [ __ ] like a faux hawk and
it was [ __ ] black and uh she wore all
kinds of [ __ ] cool little punk rock
outfits and she had the tattoo of a
black widow on her back shoulder it was
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
back in [ __ ] 87. she was about
she was underage for a tattoo too young
for a tattoo she still had it
she was probably about 17.
and then uh grandmother camp
grandfather's probably remembers them
[ __ ] the other two punk rock girls
[ __ ] [ __ ] what was their names
they were [ __ ] superstars back they
were um superstars back in the day and
i'm getting sidetracked yeah no [ __ ]
yeah bill ohlinger's friends he knows
what i'm talking about
you're talking about people who 99 of us
don't know who yeah bill linger was a
[ __ ] black guy [ __ ] we went to
school with
camp guy says i've already had about
three basal cell carcinomas and one
squamous cell cancers cut off my skin
yeah
skin cancer it's a thing and a lot of
people do have in florida man you see
some people not so much nowadays but
like you see some older people walking
around florida that look like [ __ ]
leather boots man
especially people that have like you
know lived outdoors like they're really
into like boating and fishing and [ __ ]
like that some of those people man that
was that's really really bad i just i
don't know i never got into it like i
said my mom's really into the beach and
she used to take us a lot as a kid but
i didn't really like it
i mean it was kind of fun but i didn't
really like being out in the sun i don't
like being sunburned i kind of like
swimming in the ocean but sharks you
know i like swimming in a pool better
than sharks all right i got a picture
there
there's gene
remember gene
graham
that was 1987.
yeah
oracle says my stepbrother died from
skin cancer he had a landscaping
business
yeah i mean honestly i don't know people
that work outdoors in florida i don't
know how they [ __ ] do it you must put
on like some [ __ ] nuclear
sunblock i mean i would if i were you
because
that shit's not fun
uh it'll make you look old at you know
at best and at worst you'll just get
[ __ ] skin cancer
john gore says didn't the dead milkman
have a punk rock girl song they did yeah
and it was called punk rock girl yeah
that i still love that song to be honest
with you
i love why do i still remember this the
video for it
the punk rock girl that was in there was
actually a real punk rock girl with a
big huge green mohawk
and she was in a band and the band's
name was god's crotch
why do i remember that i don't know but
i do
um
my favorite
line in that song
was uh the verse where they go to the
record store
and they ask for mojo nixon and the guy
says he don't work here
and
we said if you don't got mojo nixon then
your store could use some fixing that
just [ __ ] made me laugh if you don't
know if the kids don't know who mojo
nixon is uh look that [ __ ] up
but it's just like i don't know that
just made me laugh oh and also the part
about her uh stealing the car that like
made me laugh too
like i said him yeah they get in the car
we get into a car away we started
rolling
i said how much you pay for this she
said nothing man it's stolen yeah
that's a funny ass song i like that i
guess graham's gone he's not responding
on there yeah i don't see anything yeah
he's gone
uh dj maniac says i'm friends with
rodney anonymous from the dead milkman
he makes industrial music now and plays
well with us that's awesome he always
seemed like an okay dude
yeah oracle said uh the one that died of
skin cancer yeah 30 diabetes 30. yeah
it'll happen like i said
[ __ ] man
janet says i grew up in nebraska we
sunbathed on roofs used baby oil i
burned to a crisp swede here yeah i also
have had basal cell carcinoma
yeah yeah
a lot of michiganders are like [ __ ]
scandinavian um
sophie is one of them
who's the friend of the show
and she's from michigan she's from the
same little hometown me and krampus grew
up in nasa this is the way they looked
yup [ __ ]
that that
she's been here she's actually been on
the show before but that's the
coloration that's typical
for in michigan
they don't tan
i was teasing her i called her a honky
ice princess she goes yeah that's
exactly what i am well the thing about
it is princess my [ __ ] uh you know my
[ __ ] dna is
you know kind of like half irish half
native american but my ass doesn't tan
either no yeah i'm like
pale as a [ __ ] and like i said
i lay out in the sun and i just burn
after about 20 minutes it just turns red
it doesn't go tan
uh oracle says how is sophie doing
haven't seen her no she's good she's
good she's uh
uh well she's she's going through some
[ __ ] she's gonna um
she may be around after a while we'll
see i don't want to i don't want to tell
her business
but uh i'll leave that to her she's
listening she usually gets on the show a
couple days after we post
because she's working yeah because not
everybody can do like the last yeah she
can't do the live thing too much so uh
she may she we may see her around in a
couple months we'll see how things go
she's going through a change of life
not that one though no not that change
i was gonna say she's going through a
change of scenery okay
she may or may not say change of life
most people think menopause menopause
[Laughter]
she's a little young for menopause she
may or may not stay in um
michigan we'll see
mr roboto says have you tried tanning
jenny body butter i you know honestly i
don't really like the tan look uh
personally it's not aesthetically
attractive to me so i never really
wanted to
do that i have tried other various
tanning things when i was younger when
that was kind of more of a thing
and nothing worked uh you know i usually
i would just burn
red counts as a tan it's a red tan
it's just a red peely
tan it's very attractive
uh so let's talk a little bit about uh
again probably one of the most common
urban legends babysitter and the man
upstairs now this has been uh
fictionalizing a lot of movies when a
stranger calls black christmas uh tons
of other ones
um so this
story actually originated
uh in the 1960s
and usually like i said it's a teenage
girl she's babysitting a couple of kids
and keeps getting phone calls from a
stalker person who keeps asking her to
check the children uh most of the time
the children do not survive uh as indeed
i don't think they do in the movie
either wait in the movie did they live
when a stranger calls oh [ __ ] now i
can't remember because i'm getting it
confused with all the different versions
of the story but in most versions of the
urban legend
the children get killed and in some
versions of the urban legend the
babysitter gets killed as well now what
a lot of people might not know though
is that
this urban legend uh possibly stemmed
from a real
case
uh the real case happened in 1950
and this was a girl named janet
christman and i think she was only 14 or
15 if i'm not mistaken
uh it happened in missouri
and she was babysitting a little
three-year-old kid named greg
and
uh the parents were going out with like
another couple they were like going out
to play cards or some [ __ ] like that
and the dad actually left her a shotgun
and like showed her how to shoot it and
everything like how to load it and
whatnot and left it by the door so this
is 1950 in missouri and
apparently at some time during the night
she called the police
and said something like please get here
quick
but then they
you know she didn't talk anymore so they
couldn't uh trace it you know it was in
1950
and so they didn't know where they were
supposed to go to
and when the parents got home
they found the girl the babysitter and
she had been violently
raped and murdered
and was just laying in the
uh living room with the phone like off
the hook now the kid
uh was alive actually the kid didn't
even wake up the whole time uh so the
kid survived uh unlike in the urban
legend but uh unfortunately the teenage
babysitter was raped and murdered and i
think that maybe most folklores think
that maybe this real event is what
spurred the whole babysitter in the
verse because there have been a million
like variations of this and like i said
there have been tons and tons of movies
of it i got a feeling she knew who did
it
um
maybe not it might have just been some
rando you don't know or it could have
been a [ __ ] neighbor i don't know
i mean it was probably somebody that
knew she was there alone yeah
but funny that the kid didn't wake up
i mean he was three yeah okay that young
yeah
so it's not like i don't think it's that
weird right i mean you know and the kids
are probably just kind of like if they
wake up you're three you're just kind of
like what's that whatever
you know you know you don't really know
what's going on three three yes that's
young yeah interestingly there have been
a lot more modern versions of this which
inject like a clown thing because i kind
of feel like in the last
10 20 years
urban legends about clowns have
proliferated because everybody's decided
that clowns are scary which i you know
they are
um
but so you know you had that whole urban
legend about like all the clowns like
turning up in the various cities and
doing [ __ ] which
it did happen a couple times but it
didn't happen in all the times and
places that have been attributed to it
but even the clown [ __ ] has like
kind of wormed its way into this classic
legend more modern versions of the
babysitter in the man upstairs story uh
usually instead of like the dude calling
and saying hey check the children or
whatever because that's a little bit
old-fashioned you know from a modern
perspective
but
usually what happens in the modern
versions is that she goes up to check on
the kids
and there is
a clown thing in the corner that she
thinks is a statue
and she's weirded out by it
and then
when one of the parents calls to check
on the kids she says hey can like i
don't really like that freaky clown
statue that's in your kid's room can i
put a blanket over it or something and
they're just like clown statue what are
you talking about we don't have a clown
statue in the kid's room at which point
we're just kind of like uh oh you know
what i mean because it's like a [ __ ]
serial killer looking like a clown
because i kind of feel like nowadays you
have to add a scary clown to everything
because that's just
what we do
it nowadays
how many horror movies in the past 20
years have there been with [ __ ] scary
clowns in them
we saw a shitty ass scary clown movie
the whole [ __ ] movie was [ __ ]
remember that
uh yeah what was that called we reviewed
it stupid as hell it was about that
clown themed hotel motel was it not
somewhat i've seen some good clown
themed movies yeah she was terrible i've
seen some good ones was that one with
that [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] clown
what was the name of the terrorizer
that yeah and that was called terrorizer
yeah that was a good one the rest of
them and that was based on that was uh
art the clown yeah that one was good
yeah super gory yeah well that was kind
of based on a character that and i think
i maybe reviewed it or we talked about
it like on our halloween show like a
couple years back that came from an
anthology movie
called all hallows eve i want to say and
art the clown was like introduced and
then like people responded to that so
well that he got his own movie which was
terrifier um but yeah so if you like
gore like watch terrifier that's a
really good killer clown movie uh there
was another one that was just called
clown
that was about a guy
that
he uh like the clown that he hired for
his kid's birthday party couldn't show
up
so he found a clown costume and wore it
himself and it turned out that the clown
costume was actually
the skin
of a demon
called a cloin
yeah clown so it like so it like fused
like the rainbow hair like fused to his
hair and the nose fused to his nose i
remember that that was good
and and he ends up like eating children
like he doesn't want to and it's
awesome yeah i forgot about it it's
really good that one's actually better
than terra it's really good it's called
a clown
it's just called clown clown yeah i
can't remember what year it came out it
was 2015 maybe 14. somewhere around
there maybe 2013 i don't remember but it
yeah it was really good but that's the
best if you look it up look up yeah it
it was a d it's a demon called a coin
clone that it does like oh well that's
what all the modern clown stuff is based
on this old demon and it's this guy that
puts on this clown suit and it
essentially becomes fused to him and it
turns him into
a child eating demon yeah it's rad and
it's like it's really a demon skin and
it's really gory and it's and so many
children get horribly eaten and
mutilated in this it's wonderful and the
demon skin is [ __ ] bizarre it looks
like a clown outfit but that's its skin
that's a good idea yes i want to see
that one again i wonder if there's a uh
what if there's a sequel
i don't know i don't i don't know if
there was but yeah that was actually one
of the i think that was the best clown
horror movie that i said well i mean
killer clowns from outer space is good
um you know it
that was a good clown movie but
clown was better but yeah i really did i
actually really did like that one i did
like that one but i i i feel like it's
one of those things where horror movies
i feel like there was a big thing like
oh clowns are scary so now we're gonna
like do all the clown horror movies it's
kind of like all the shark horror movies
all the ouija horror movies ouija shark
all the crossovers was there a clown
shark probably
let's check on toby i'm sure it's there
but um you know
i i don't know i
th the more uh movies that you make with
scary clowns in them the less scary they
are yeah i mean they are kind of scary i
get it but
i don't know to me like puppet
marionette ventriloquist dummies are
scarier than clowns and even that's like
not super scary depending on how you do
it but i just kind of feel like it's too
common nowadays and it's just kind of
like oh boy another like clown horror
movie but there have been good ones and
clown is actually like really really
good
uh the clown in the original poltergeist
was scary yeah i agree and i kind of
feel like maybe
i don't know maybe that's kind of where
the scary clown thing came from i don't
know would when did the novel of it come
out
because i kind of feel like you know
pennywise kind of went a long way toward
that but i
feel like maybe that was more the movie
that did that than the book
and i don't think the movie came out
until 1990 or 1991 so i can't remember
mr robotta says is the jersey devil an
urban legend it is i we're not going to
cover it because we talked about the
jersey devil on one of our cryptid shows
and
like i said i don't
i kind of feel like cryptids and urban
legends even though they're kind of the
same thing i've you know we did cryptid
shows so i wanted to keep that kind of
separate
i mean
yeah folklore i mean folklore and urban
legends it's kind of the same thing
folklore i kind of feel like is more
maybe [ __ ] that's rooted in older [ __ ]
whereas like urban legends are usually
like more modern things but sometimes
the modern urban legends are based on
older folklore just modernized for
whatever
but
yeah so
yeah they did the kids did die in the
movie right and
when a stranger calls i know they've
made more than one movie about the
babysitter
uh legend but that's the one that most
people remember is when a stranger calls
and we've talked about that before too
that's kind of like pretty much a
straightforward telling of that story
but there are like variations of it
where the kids survive uh there's some
variations of it which are you know kind
of lame i have to say that it turns out
that it wasn't even a killer it was just
somebody pulling a prank which
yeah you know again that seems
kind of dumb it's not like you want kids
to get killed but
if it's a story
you want some horror come on you know
what i mean let me do one more and then
uh i'll cook us something to eat
well okay let me talk about let me do a
couple more hours yeah let me do a
couple more because um there's a couple
that i really wanted to talk about oh
[ __ ] i want to talk with as well i guess
i'm going to have to skip that i'll have
to do a whole show about that we can
always do another show on this i mean
yeah i'm going to have to but a couple
of the ones that have stuff there i know
well like i said
four hours i told you
well you know if you didn't go off on so
many photos she's blaming me see this is
how she's
if i didn't say anything you uh this
show would still be three hours
well yeah because i have a lot of uh
content you would never cut you would
never cover all that see this is how she
does yeah i would just actually do this
clash of fred says there's a tale about
a doll called robert that is said to be
inspiration for chucky from child's play
we i kind of feel like we talked about
robert the doll because that's a florida
based story i think he's in fort
lauderdale or i don't know there's
something about that but we have talked
about that before i just can't remember
what show it was on thank you zach is it
weird clowns don't scare me but drag
queens too
[Laughter]
john gore says weren't they originally
supposed to call the original halloween
the babysitter murders yes they were
they were gonna call it that and it was
uh largely based on
that urban legend which like i said was
based on a real thing but
you know obviously it's been embellished
so here's an urban legend which maybe a
lot of people don't know but this is
actually one of my favorite ones and
i feel like the first time i read this
one
was back in the 70s or early 80s when i
was a kid in this book right here which
my grandfather gave me i think called
strange stories amazing facts this was a
reader's digest book
and i [ __ ] loved this book i read it
like a million times when i was a kid
there's all kind of crazy [ __ ] in here
it's not all it's there's like sections
about like weird unsolved mysteries like
paranormal and [ __ ] like that but
there's then there's like a lot of just
like amazing
science facts and historical facts and
[ __ ] like that so it's not all [ __ ]
i'm just saying that but there's a story
in here and in here
the story is called
long at the fair
uh but the story is usually sometimes
also called the vanishing hotel room
this story always [ __ ] fascinated me
now in this book
this came out in the early 1970s i think
1972 or 1974
and the story in this book was under the
unsolved mysteries
section
and it was told as though it was a true
story like it had details like it was a
true story and everything
a story goes
uh usually in most versions of it
so
there's usually a woman and her daughter
and
normally they're going to paris
for
um
the exposition which happened in 1889
1900 right around there thank you janet
a drink for you and tom enjoying the
show thank you very much
you guys are awesome
um
yeah so it's usually a mother and
daughter and they're
usually from india
and they're coming to paris for the
exposition and they came through
marseille so they come to paris
they stay in a hotel they check into the
hotel
not too long after checking into the
hotel
the mom
gets sick
and so you know like the doctor comes
and the hotel manager and everything
like that
the doctor comes and examines the mom
and then goes to the daughter and says
um well uh i can't leave the patient
right now so
we need this specific medicine and it's
only at this one pharmacy
and it's on the other side of paris so
you have to take my carriage and go get
it
um and then bring it back here like for
your mom
so the girl
gets in the carriage and goes but it
takes like a really long time now
usually there's reasons like oh because
of the exposition like there's a [ __ ]
ton of people in the city and it's like
everything's backed up or because she
can't really speak french and so she's
having a hard time communicating with
people or whatever but for whatever
reason
it usually ends up taking about four
hours
for her for her to go to the pharmacy
get the medication and come back to the
hotel
when she comes back to the hotel
she discovers
that
her mother is gone
and that nobody at the hotel
seems to remember
that she checked in with her mother
um
basically the story the version that i
heard and the version that's in here
that has like a lot of details including
like the room number which is 342. and
all these other things
so the daughter comes back and she says
hey i got the medication where's my mom
and eat now like the person that checked
them into the hotel is like wait like
what are you talking about you checked
in by yourself and the daughter's like
the [ __ ] are you talking about i checked
in here with my mom like four hours ago
check the book like where you sign in
and she looks at the book and she sees
her name
there like she signed it but the name
above where her mom signed it is
somebody else's name
so she's like no man we're in room 342
or whatever and so they take her up to
that room and they go in there and the
room is totally different like the
you know the decor and everything is
like totally different her mom is not
there nobody knows her mom nobody says
she checked in with her mom and it's
like this [ __ ] crazy ass story
so this story was reported as true in
this book and has been reported as true
i mean
going back a long way this story
actually goes back much farther than i
realized like when i went back and
researched it
most iterations of the story um
kind of go to the point where the
daughter
somehow like does some kind of
investigation and she figures out that
what happened
was that her mom
had the plague
and so they decided that rather than let
that news get out because the exposition
was going on and they didn't want you
know we have to close the beaches it was
like a tourist situation they didn't
want like you know anything any bad uh
publicity getting out so they said well
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
completely cover this up we're going to
redecorate the room
where they where she was we're gonna
hide the body we're gonna pretend that
she was never here
and we're just gonna you know so most
versions of the story have the daughter
like
you know obviously because everyone's
telling her that her mom didn't exist
and she'd never she checked in alone
which she knew she didn't and she ends
up going to like an insane asylum later
on and that was actually dramatized in
like several movies this was actually
turned up and like i didn't know this
when i first read the story because like
i said i was a kid when i read that i
was like man that's crazy um but yeah so
so it's supposed to lay this big cover
up where somehow inexplicably they
redecorated a whole entire hotel suite
in like four hours which i don't buy
that no but okay um but it's a cool
story anyway but they actually made this
into a movie it was in like a bunch of
novels i think that
the earliest novel that it was in maybe
was from like 1913 i want to say it was
in like a bunch of movies too there were
some movies called there was one called
uh bunny lake is missing from 1957 that
kind of had a similar thing although
there's some details we're missing uh
there was another film in 1938 called
the lady vanishes which i think was an
early alfred hitchcock if i'm not
mistaken uh and that was kind of a
similar thing but didn't have some of
the elements
um but as i said there was a novel that
came out in 1934
uh by alexander wolcott that had this
same story in it
uh and he said that the story was true
and he had got it from a detroit
newspaper back in 1889
but that's never been verified so again
this seems like a story that was
keeps being reported as true
but
nobody can really find like a source for
it and like i said it's see it's a cool
story but it seems
far-fetched
people like this story because it kind
of
it kind of feeds into this whole like
paranoia [ __ ]
about
i mean how would that feel if you like
just yeah your mom's sick and you go off
to get medication four hours later you
come back and everybody pretends like
they don't know who your mom is and you
weren't with your mom
and the room's different that you
checked into i mean how [ __ ] freaky
would that be and then they just keep
telling you that
yes like yeah and then like eventually
you just think well i must be crazy then
and that's usually how most of the
stories end up i don't know why like i
always really liked that story it's i
don't know it just has a very rosemary's
baby vibe to me where it looks like
everybody's like gaslighting you into
like thinking that your mom but like i
said some of the stories do have like
the resolution where she found out that
it was like a big cover-up because the
mom had the plague and they didn't want
anybody to know about it so they
disposed of her
i don't know why they would redecorate a
whole hotel room just to like do that
but you know you'd think they would just
kind of maybe
change a couple things around
but not like a whole entire four hours
really doesn't seem to be like long
enough to do that
so another one i wanted to uh talk about
oh i was going to say too that the show
uh beyond belief
do you remember like that show i think
yeah that sounds familiar yeah it was on
like travel channel or something like
that uh they actually portrayed this as
a true story as recently as 2002 so this
is still circulating or was at least
like 20 years ago as
a true story and as i said in this book
they did actually portray it as a true
story as far as i know it's not
i don't know where it came from
but it has been in a lot of
novels and [ __ ] like that so i kind of
feel like it's just been
kind of i don't know it's just one that
i always really liked
here's another one i'll talk about
really briefly the black volga now this
is actually not an american one this is
a poland uh hungary russia belarus
ukraine greece mongolia
this is a story that kind of went around
a lot in the 1960s and 1970s
and this is um
usually it's a black car
and it goes around like abducting people
usually children
now different versions of the story uh
give different versions as to who's
driving it sometimes it's uh priests or
nuns
sometimes it's jews
sometimes it's communists
uh sometimes it's vampires or satan
russian mafia there's all kind of
different like [ __ ] [ __ ] so this car
is specifically usually in the older
versions of the story is the black vulga
uh white wheel rims white curtains
uh or other like white things inside the
car
so this like drives around like
kidnapping people
and
the children that are kidnapped are
usually their blood is drained
uh to cure rich westerners
or arabs who are suffering from leukemia
uh also
uh there are variations of this uh used
like organ theft which like you were
talking about before
uh you know kgb is like stealing
people's organs going around these
[ __ ] cards he wasn't interested in
that [ __ ] well no but like i said it's
an urban legend so it's a very common
urban legend in that part of the world
or at least it was in the 60s and 70s of
this particular black car driving around
kidnapping people and like taking their
organs in their blood or whatever uh
late 20th century uh you got like other
versions of it usually then it would be
like a mercedes or a bmw
sometimes the uh license plate had 666
on it because of course it did um
uh here is another i like this variation
too
the driver would ask passersby for the
current time
and kill them when they approach the car
to answer
in another version of the legend the
victim would die at the same time a day
later ooh that's like the ring or some
[ __ ] like that uh the dr yeah the driver
will tell them tomorrow you'll die at
this hour
another version of legends says that if
you uh when the driver of the volga
asked you what time is it
you had to answer it is god's time and
then they would leave you alone okay
[Laughter]
so that was russian
that's how you could like circumvent it
right which is like that's like super
super funny
but uh yeah i don't know i just like
really like that story i like that i
like the idea of like some black car
like driving around like kidnapping
people now uh the russians had a damn
superhero movie based on the damn vulga
i think they did yeah about a russian uh
he was like it was a it was a magic
vulgar didn't it fly and have all kinds
of [ __ ] yeah and now that you mention
it i think that yeah it might have that
and that might have been because like i
said this is pretty common yeah yeah
this is a pretty common urban legend in
that part of the world um i don't know
about nowadays i don't know if it's that
widespread now
but back in the 60s and 70s and 80s it
was like very very common yeah uh so
yeah i imagine though yeah i think it
was like 2010 2015 around that period i
saw a damn russian superhero movie the
guy had this damn [ __ ] flying
shitty [ __ ] black commie car from the
soviet era and he's like not really
respecting he's like oh this whole car
and it turns out it's kind of like the
batmobile it has all kinds of
special powers and [ __ ] i want to see
like throw some tacks like to flatten
your tires and lasers and stuff like
that he's kind of like
he's kind of like a russian regular guy
you know i mean also he's got this
badass car and he becomes a superhero
because of it i wouldn't mind seeing it
again it was okay this was fun i think
it was a vulgar
i mean there have been a lot of movies
based on urban legends because people
were making fun of him because he was
driving it yeah it was just an old
communist car you know and everybody
else had modern cars like hondas right
you know i want to see it again the
thing about urban legends is that the
nice thing about them is that nobody
owns that story so you can make a movie
based on that you don't have to pay
anybody so you know that there's that
now so the last one i want to talk about
talking about vehicular kind of stuff
there was other [ __ ] i wanted i wanted
to get into a whole cursed paintings
thing but we're not gonna get into that
so i'm gonna have to like save that for
another show
this is one that i just found today i've
never heard this one before apparently
this is a
philadelphia specific urban legend
this is the bust to nowhere see i love
this kind of stuff because this is like
it's not
super murdery
but it's just like ambiguous enough to
be like super creepy
so apparently in the philadelphia area
there is a bus
that looks kind of like their regular
you know city buses
but it doesn't have like a destination
on it or anything like that
and the story goes that if you are
having like a really like hard time in
your life like you [ __ ] hit bottom
whatever you know problems you got
this bus
will kind of like drive by
and
kind of like look at you or whatever and
then like it'll come back around
and if you hit you have to hail it yeah
if you hail it
you get on
they don't charge you any money the
driver does not look at you yeah you
just get on the bus none of the other
passengers look at you so you get on
this bus and you just sit on this bus
and
while you're on the bus
you can't see like the outside it's
almost kind of like it's in some kind of
weird like dimension or something
and you're on the bus for as long as it
takes you
to sort out your [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so you could be
on there for like hours you'd be on
there for years the bus it moves but it
does you can't like see where it's going
i thought you could tell me that the bus
pulls over and you get in there and
turns out you got to go on tour with
anvil
that's a whole other variation
i think i'd rather be on the bus to
nowhere to be honest with you yeah tour
the anvil
but the weird okay so you're on this bus
for like a long time and then apparently
if you've sorted out your [ __ ]
and you think like okay i've sorted out
my [ __ ] now you're in like this other
like weird bus dimension
and you you know pull the cord to get
off and the bus will drop you off the
same place that you picked it up now it
might be hours it might be years later
you don't know
but you get out and you've supposedly
like sorted your [ __ ] out and you can
turn your life around now
now the bus
if you're having some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
it comes by you and you don't hail it
when it comes back by that's the only
chance you're gonna get it's not gonna
like come back again
it's almost kind of like the bus is like
a redemption
kind of thing
i have never heard this
story i hadn't heard it before today and
i don't think that it has
i feel like it doesn't have an
equivalent in other places this is a
very philadelphia specific
and some people have said that they've
been on this bus
and this buzz it just drives around it
doesn't go anyplace and you can't see
where it's going the only way that you
know that it's time to get off is if
you can suddenly see like the city
lights outside
um instead of just like nothingness and
that means
okay you need to get off now and like
get on with your life you've sorted out
the [ __ ] that you need to sort out and
now you need to like turn your life
around this is a self-help boss it is
yeah it's like a cr well it's a creepy
self-help because that's pretty creepy
i don't know there's something really
creepy about that like it's kind of nice
i mean as far as most urban look because
usually i like like the real gruesome
urban legends this one is not gruesome
but for some reason that one it makes it
kind of creepier because it's like
ambiguous what does the bus want weird
why does the bus want you to like come
in the bus who made that [ __ ] up this is
kind of it's kind of like the where it's
like the
i don't know man it's like it's like the
weird like purgatory bus is it's like a
twilight zone yeah it's like the
twilight zone purgatory bus and for some
reason like [ __ ] like that is like
creepier to me than like straight up
murdery [ __ ] i don't know why just
because you don't know like what the
motive is i guess i don't know but i
just found that today and i was just
kind of like wow that's some creepy ass
[ __ ]
i don't know what
honestly i'd be kind of curious though
if i actually did see the bust of
nowhere and it like stopped by me or
went by me i'd be like i'm getting on
about something i'm gonna see what
happens i would totally do that
i'm just saying the midnight meat buzz
yeah we'll see that's what i thought of
i thought of the midnight meat train
that clyde barker story which uh was
much more murdery this one not so
murdery it just seems like like you said
like it's kind of like a twilight zone
episode okay we're coming up on four
hours is there anything else you guys
want to talk about any questions or
anything we can drop them down in the
comments section if not then we're gonna
go ahead and we're gonna [ __ ] shut it
down yeah i guess not like i said there
were some other stuff i wanted to get
like into cursed paintings but because i
had a couple of those but i don't know
we'll save that for another show for
another show probably some of this stuff
probably do a whole show on two or three
of those
yeah i probably could actually we should
you know what we should do a whole
cursed objects show i'm gonna write that
down actually because then i can talk
about the like the paintings that i had
yeah although we did a show about like i
remember we did one we didn't do a whole
show about it we talked about remember
the dybbuk box
that we talked about i think we talked
about that oh we did a show about
horror movies that were based on real
things so we talked about like the that
suicide forest and
the watcher i think we talked about that
case and i think we talked about the
debit box and one other thing
but
i don't know i i like like cursed object
type of stories too so that i had like
three different like cursed painting
stories that i was going to talk about
that were urban legends but janet says
yeah that sounds good we'll do one of
those but we'll get into that yeah
um victor says i'd get on the bang bus
yeah yeah
i think i've been on a bench
jenny might have been on that too i
probably was just driving you should get
on the short bus that's all florida [ __ ]
by the way
all this porn you guys are [ __ ]
jerking it too that's all florida
down the miami area actually some of the
shits around here in uh orlando i
[ __ ] recognize some of the [ __ ]
backgrounds some of the [ __ ] they got
freaky zoids up here
well yeah like i said all the weirdos
from the rest of the country moved to
florida because like oh it's nice and
warm down there we're sick of winter so
all the [ __ ] freaks moved in well
you can't do that in hollywood anymore
the porn scene just left california it's
just not a good environment for it
[ __ ] uh but florida yeah it's [ __ ]
it's it's it's slamming down here
last time we [ __ ] went to uh
uh what was the [ __ ] club uh
uh
knights uh [ __ ] what escape there's
no doubt that southern night southern
knights were at southern knights at one
time remember they had some [ __ ] porn
star chicks that were in the vip area
and we're like vip area what kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] is this this whole [ __ ]
club is vip and that [ __ ] is up there
by herself all the time
it's [ __ ] whole night remember that
yeah remember that kind of
[ __ ]
that club is a good club i like that
club i think it's still there it's still
there we just
uh the dude who threw that knight's dead
uh and yeah
we've had a lot of people in the scene
have [ __ ] died in the last few years
creepily
they're [ __ ] with bad drugs well it
wasn't always that sometimes it was
cancer
we had a guy die like in a car accident
that happened too right the the
particular guy i'm talking about who was
running the club scene who yeah he died
from he died that was drugs and um
i was like well what drug was it and
they were like we don't really know the
family's not really saying anything and
[ __ ] i was going i wonder if that was
fentanyl
because they said that that fentanyl
is cheap and real easy to od on and he
wasn't [ __ ] really rich enough to owe
dion coke
it must have been fentanyl
i don't know i don't know i wasn't there
i hadn't seen him in a while yeah then i
found out he died
he had too much weight on him to be a
[ __ ] coke addict
he was eating i don't think of fentanyl
oscar says tom did you see the video of
the huge crocodile that had eaten that
guy which guy they were hauling it on
the tractor massive crocodile that had a
dude in its stomach
i don't know what guy you're talking
about i've seen a lot of dudes a lot of
crocodiles a lot of alligators crocodile
there's no crocodiles in florida we only
have allergies well no he didn't say it
was florida okay he just said it was a
crocodile and so that could be anywhere
could be anywhere i've seen a lot of
that [ __ ] i mean i've seen crocodiles
that were easily big enough to eat a
person so
i'll have to look that i don't know if i
want to look that up though it's like an
alligator can get [ __ ] huge man i
don't know if uh if an alligator is
bigger than a crocodile the best
crocodiles are generally bigger are they
bigger yeah i mean i've seen some big
ass alligators too but generally if you
see this big [ __ ] giant [ __ ]
that's usually a crocodile um i do know
this uh crocodiles tend to be more
aggressive they have a they have
generally there yet they have a more
aggressive reputation
and alligator actually can kind of
become cohabitated with humans um me and
my dad been fishing when i was a kid and
have alligators swim up next to the boat
and start begging for fish
and then [ __ ] won't go away
give them a couple fish they'll stand
there
you give them three or four fish they'll
try to get the fifth fish they'll try to
get the sixth fish
and they won't go away so then you just
hit him with a [ __ ] fishing rod pop
out and then they'll they'll submerge
like a
like a uh submarine and disappear
you know because you don't want those
[ __ ] around the fishing boat all day
they'll they'll eat the fish that you
caught you're reeling one in and they'll
go for it
and then what do you what what do you
end up with a damn alligator on the end
of your line
and of course you can't get a [ __ ]
12-foot alligator into the boat
so you got to break the line and then
he's swimming around with a [ __ ] hook
in his mouth
so beating them with the fishing rod is
actually a humane way of get the [ __ ]
out of here you're gonna get hurt
but uh in lake clark of mississippi
there are a lot of pet alligators that
size
going up coming up begging for fish i
was never really scared of them
victor points out that florida and this
is true florida is indeed the only place
in the world that has crocodiles and
alligators living together that'd be the
everglades you know i didn't know there
was crocodiles there yes there are they
must have been released into the wild or
maybe how did they get up there well the
thing about florida like i said if you
we have so many invasive species they're
like not even invasives there's fish
because it's belong here there's
everything nothing belongs here nothing
belongs here because of the i mean i'm
not gonna say that but the the climate
is such that if you release anything
pretty much into the wild it's going to
proliferate yeah oh [ __ ] nutra it's
hot and humid
and
there's animals and woods and swamps and
[ __ ] like that everywhere so they'll be
like wee
nutra don't belong here they're in there
in louisiana and it's like a giant rat
type thing
and they're they they love eating those
damn
water plants
and uh
they're an invasive species there's kind
of like a bounty on them on nutra
so guys have taken to eating them
because cajun will eat anything
and you can make good
food out of them uh even gordon ramsay
went down there to experiment with what
they were doing with nutra
another one
it's been rumored that capibada are down
there which is a big [ __ ] brazilian
giant
groundhog the size of a dog
i don't know if it's true but
it might be it might be just a rumor
but a neutral you or you meant a
capibata you would think that that could
survive
the everglades or or like i said most
animals
find the climate in florida to their
liking like bubble constrictors are
really not from here in anaconda but i
was going to say a lot of people have
them as pets if they escape or people
release them into the wild we have like
whole now now they live here
yeah they didn't use they're not native
to here no but they were just kind of
like hooray all right
um and there's a lot of fish that don't
belong here that are [ __ ] thriving uh
jeremy wade was getting into that uh
some of them are [ __ ] big like uh
what's it called uh arapaima yeah which
are they're giant and they're dangerous
you know they're known for jumping out
of the water and hitting you
dead in the chest
and killing you
that's how big they are you know well
this 60 pound fish it's like getting hit
in the chest by a [ __ ] lamb or a pig
you know or a sledgehammer
and uh they found dudes dead floating in
the water they're not sure what killed
them they think it might have been
arapaima
slasher fred says if you guys ever
watched that show beyond belief fact or
fiction yeah i've seen some of those uh
some of the stories were inspired by
urban legend yep
and uh victor also said yeah crocodiles
are native to florida yeah all right uh
yeah well like i said everybody said
that's that's the only place that
crocodiles and alligators as far as i
know only place in the world that they
live together
um
uh oscar says jenny have you seen the
movie begotten i have uh i actually
wrote about it for my blog
that is uh
one of the most
similar to a nightmare movies that i've
ever seen
it's uh
if you haven't seen it it's from the 90s
like the early 90s
it's the same guy that directed shadow
the vampire which is also excellent
but he made it look like
a silent film and it looks like a silent
film from the 1920s
uh and
it's
weird it's like symbolic and it's just
like really actually there were like
gifts from it that were floating around
as like ooh creepy [ __ ] you know what i
mean but it's from that movie it's if
you haven't seen it but i watched on
youtube i don't know so they're saying
uh crocodiles are native to uh florida
they're not native to mississippi or
louisiana
only alligator
but man weird [ __ ] could happen
okay
mississippi river is huge and it feeds
lakes
bull shark can go up in the mississippi
river in fresh water
well i've seen people have been
evidently killed or missed just
disappeared mysteriously on the
mississippi river and some of these
larger rakes lakes and places like even
mississippi
and they suspect bull shark
or shark
well
where i grew up in daytona beach uh if
you guys don't know it's daytona beach
it's kind of like you have like the
mainland
and then there's the halifax river
and then there's like a strip of land
and then there's the ocean
now the halifax river eventually if you
go far south enough feeds into the
atlantic so uh sometimes i have actually
seen in the river
uh i have seen dolphins in there and i
have seen sharks in there occasionally
so it does happen because it's connected
it's not really that far so that it
actually they can like swim up into it
and back out into the position again
i've been a kid swimming around in some
of these mississippi freshwater lakes
and in [ __ ] tributaries of the
[ __ ] mississippi type river and
there's other
rivers that [ __ ] go through
there you know the water's not deep four
feet maybe in the center of the river
it's not very wide across you know 30
feet
and i would have been surprised
surprised as hell to be inner tubing and
swimming
in fresh water and just out of the blue
get [ __ ] eaten by a [ __ ] hungry
ass shark
in fresh water where it isn't supposed
to be
imagine that
because there were times when i was
swimming
afraid of jaws because i saw the movie
but then reassuring myself now there
could never be a shark out here it's
fresh water
little john scared me so much that i
thought well i don't even know if it was
so much jaws but it was like that james
bond movie where like the sharks came
out in the pool
so when i was a kid like even swimming
in a pool i was like i know that's
stupid but
some like super villain could release
some sharks into this pool right now and
eat me yeah and that it was always like
in the back of my mind
there's all kinds of [ __ ] youtube
videos of people going in their
backyards and [ __ ] seeing black bear
see that all time and then they go in
the backyard and look in the pool and
there's a big ass [ __ ] alligator in
their pool they're like what
yeah alligator just chilling what you
doing you know get out of my pool like
no i'm good
what is it
yeah
and in clean water clean fresh looking
water you can see right to the bottom
[ __ ] 11 foot alligator just sitting
up in there going chilling
in your backyard in your pool in the
middle of the [ __ ] well it happens a
lot in florida it happens a lot in
florida and i kind of feel like if you
have a pool in florida then at some
point you walked out and probably found
an alligator in there at some point or
something deer swimming in it or
something yeah or some animal yeah yeah
be like hey thank you yeah
uh danny rolling ghostface said one more
story jenny all right one more very very
quick story all right okay
we're gonna talk about the hundred step
cemetery all right i just heard about
this it's literally a really free story
it's a really short story okay now this
is in brazil
indiana i didn't know there was a town
called brazil in indiana oh man there's
there's something there there's athens
in every [ __ ] city well i know that i
mean i know that but i didn't know that
it was like cities named after like a
whole country
i know that there's like a lot of
european cities have equivalents in the
us because that's duh but i didn't know
like yeah let's call it town brazil yeah
brazil indiana
so uh there's a cemetery there although
i'm not entirely sure like where the
cemetery is exactly but it's uh
supposedly in this town
now uh the graveyard dates back to the
1860s
legend says there's all of these kind of
like steps i've seen like pictures i
don't know if this is actually the real
cemetery or not but there's like all
these steps honestly i saw a recently i
saw an asian horror movie was it
japanese
and it kind of had a version of this
legend so i'm not really sure maybe this
legend is like all over the world
so the legend is there's all these like
stone steps what you're supposed to do
is you go to the cemetery
and you climb the steps and you count
them now there's a hundred steps
and you count the steps on the way up
now at this point you get to the top of
the steps you turn around story goes
that you see
a ghost who's supposedly the undertaker
of the you know the first
you know caretaker of the cemetery or
whatever and he's standing there
now he shows you a vision
of how you will die
okay
now then you walk back down and you
count the steps again
now if you count the same number of
steps going down as you did going up
then the vision that you got shown your
death was not true will not come to pass
but
if you count a different number of steps
that means the vision that you saw will
come true
now some people have tried to circumvent
this [ __ ] by saying well i'm just going
to go because there's like steps but
there's also like a hill next to it i'm
just going to walk up the [ __ ] hill
well apparently if you try doing that
then some unseen force will smack your
ass down to the earth pow okay and
leaving a big [ __ ] red handprint on
your back
which stays there for several several
days okay so
and as i said this is very interesting
because i just i can't remember what the
name of it was but i just saw like i
think it was a japanese horror movie
we probably talked about it on the
matinee show but it was like a few
months ago that had something like this
where they were counting the steps so
they must have this same legend in other
countries
i kind of feel there's a lot of like
legends around like stairs and bridges
and [ __ ] like that because there's like
a there's one too like a a bridge in
alabama
that apparently back in the 50s like
some couple was driving across this like
wooden ass bridge and they somehow like
drove off it and you know drowned or
whatever just like in beetlejuice or
carnival of souls
and
story goes now that
you drive to the middle of the bridge
and you stop your car and turn all your
lights off
and then you turn around and you see the
ghost of the couple in the back of your
car for a second and then like they
leave like wet spots on your backseat
you know what i mean yeah which
brood
okay
i mean you know that's a good story
uh mike cohe says think about all the
deep sea creatures that are still
thriving for hundreds of thousands of
years that's the kind of [ __ ] that gives
gives me nightmares because we have no
idea what the [ __ ] is going on down
there
when i was a kid i used to have this
book
that my grandpa gave me
and it was all about sea creatures
because i was fascinated i wanted to be
a veterinarian for a little while when i
was a kid
so i was fascinated by like animals
and especially like sea creatures
and so it had this thing where
there were three like fold out
illustrations and they were showing you
all the different types of life forms
that lived at different levels like of
the ocean like here's the shallow water
fishies and here's the middle water
whatever they call it yeah yeah and i
think it was just called the fishes it
was blue
i had it and it was deep and the scary
one was the fold out with the deep sea
fishes and then some like alien looking
teeth all the way yeah like all the
teeth like all the ones were like the
weird like lantern [ __ ] like hanging off
of their heads and all this other stuff
all of them were blind
well i know it's like they tried to make
them like scarier than they were
although that book also had really
horrifying close-up shots of like sand
sharks and stuff because sand sharks
they're not i've seen them many times uh
because like i said i grew up in daytona
i hung out at the beach all the time so
i saw them i've had them brush against
my legs and [ __ ] like that they're right
there
they're not super aggressive they're not
one of the ones usually if uh somebody
gets bitten by a shark it's not usually
a sand shark because they don't usually
see people as prey
but a close-up of their mouth
they look
[ __ ] up like their teeth are all
they look like monsters honestly but
they're not super aggressive but like
the pictures that they had of sharks in
this book
traumatized me for [ __ ] life i gotta
say because most of them are like
close-ups and i'm scared of sharks
anyway
and you know no thank you no thank you
i'm staying out of the ocean from now on
so uh yeah so
what are you gonna what are you gonna
make to eat what are you gonna make to
eat i'll go down there and look i'll see
you're gonna make something i'll come up
with something
what do we have to make some japa gay
i was gonna say let's do it
like do we have some like ramen kind of
[ __ ] yeah i'm saying ramen kind of [ __ ]
sounds good
with the ground beef
or or more like kind of more traditional
ramen with eggs in it if we haven't yeah
or
i mean if you'd rather not do that we
don't have to do that but i'm just
saying i don't have the right meat to go
with that if not i have a bunch of
mexican stuff
tacos i got the uh fresh tortillas that
i made
oh okay well maybe we can do that we'll
talk about something like that in it all
right we'll see all right let's go so we
didn't do too bad i didn't like cover
some of the stories but like i said the
cursed painting stories i want to get
into that so we might do a whole show
about that at some point but uh you know
i covered some stuff
uh y'all should talk about the phoenix
lights i think we already did a show
about that did we do for sure we haven't
done lost dutch we haven't done the lost
dutchman lost dutchman
right yeah we haven't done that but we
have done phoenix lights did phoenix
slice and there's something to it
something happened i don't remember how
long ago that was but we did do a show
about that
so uh thank you everybody for
hanging out with us on this wednesday
evening we will be back again on friday
night for our regular drunk ass
sidetrack show where we just talk about
whatever like we
usually do even when we have a topic but
you know
we we can legitimately legally like talk
about whatever we want so come back on
friday evening and hang out with us
again and have a good rest of your night
have a good thursday and we will see you
guys on a friday evening
bye